pop
[Musique]
voyez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour
chers amis chers ennemis bienvenue sur
le plateau de tout le monde en parle
l'émission qui parle avec nous ce soir
michel serrault
[Applaudissements]
sara lee
à traiter ces cas là
m
'sans peillon
jean paul gaultier
[Musique]
me martial
la donne
10 juin
nadia farès
et s'il casseurs
mais
nous il amer
[Applaudissements]
une test spécial batteur axel
contre crise de multi fonctionne
là on m'a dit ah
[Applaudissements]
ben oui
je me demande où j'en étais
[Applaudissements]
sa maman lolo l'aqiii bon tri se dit
la dernière émission de la saison mais
la demi-lieue ce soir mais on se
retrouvera quand même lundi à 20h50 pour
un prime time qui s'appelle opinion
publique
alors on parlera du cannabis faut-il
mettre le cannabis en vente libre
le nudisme le nihilisme conduit-il à des
déviances sexuelles
et y at il trop de people dans les
médias voilà ses opinions publiques face
au palais lire avant oui oui comme ça ça
vous évite de regarder il faut bien le
dire on sait bien
[Musique]
ouais j michel serrault
les sens
whissell
c'est également une devise en est que
ceux qui souhaiteront ça mérite pas ça
roule c'est mérité si si un dragon à 6,6
quand même ouais ouais si si si si merci
alors alors michel 0
je vous normal
franchement là la deuxième fois c'est
pas mérité long de la saison mais là il
y en avait autant pour toi et pour
démarre sur l'hommage ça tourne au
foutage de gueule moi je tu sais comme
je t'aime toi c'est bien réciproque tête
et bien c'est bien des sols parce que
oui alors je suis dans mon monde qui
résistent surtout pas beaucoup de comics
série de comics qui trouve grâce à tes
vieilles halles a pas beaucoup en suis
pas dans les vents bat on les attendait
dans les vivants non alors michel
serrault donc le fameux sondage du
journal du dimanche qui donne le
classement des français préférés des
français
oui vous a nommé premier comédien
préféré défense mais c'est quoi sert
elle
quand on regarde on sait le succès du
journal du dimanche est sans doute dû à
la mini série de tf1 qui s'appelle la
sphère de mini çi meilleures audiences
de tf1 en 2003 12,2 millions de
téléspectateurs 50% de parts de marché
alors ce qui est intéressant
il y avait vraiment une osmose parfaite
entre entre vous michel serrault et le
personnage de gaston dominici
on vous a dit je pense qu'on avait
raison nous a dit vous ne jouez pas
dominici vous êtes 2 min tit b c'est la
vérité je suis dominici oui c'est moi
dominici je vais passer en jugement bien
peu il sera acquitté
mais ce qui est vrai c'est que souvent
on parle des méthodes de l'actor studio
où les gens pour tourner quelqu'un comme
gaston dominici vont tuer des anglais ou
en tous les cas s'immerger dans la
république dans la campagne voir comment
on nourrit les poules et et vous en fait
michel vous avez fait appel à des
souvenirs personnels n'avaient pas fait
de prévoir d'une manière enfin d'une
façon générale quand même je ne suis pas
non plus tu sais que j'ai tourné le
docteur potiez jamais mis de gonzesses
dans wii j'ai pas de chaudières à la
maison oui c'est vrai oui enfin il ya un
tas de choses comme ça je ne suis pas
non plus dans garde à vue je vais pas
assassiner la petite fille c'est vrai
c'est vrai ce que vous dites quand même
et vous avez raison
ou alors pour être comédien il faut
avoir la mémoire des autres peut-être
pas si oui nommé 3com pour jouer la
comédie il faut pas d'un parti pris et
je ne veux pas jouer avant dominici
podio sans avoir à mon avis là dessus
sinon j'ai rien à dire je me fais
remplacer alors voilà il ya beaucoup de
réflexions de cette qualité dans un
livre que michel serrault publie chez oh
éditions
qu'ils s'appellent les pieds dans le
plat j'allais le tu l'as lu alors c'est
un journal tenu de façon un petit peu
irrégulière ou bien parce qu'on n'a pas
toujours l'occasion de ouidah
c'est un peu au gré des événements oui
d'ailleurs vous posons au peut changer
si on veut changer les dates pour lui la
réflexion n'est pas avis jours près
alors on va rester dans le métier
d'acteur
si tu veux un si vous voulez pardon avec
un acteur qui s'appelle fabrice luchini
as tu un ami à moi oui vous dit fabrice
luchini m'agace qui vous agace c'est
fabrice luchini c'est qu'il a déclaré
reprendre pour la première fois le rôle
de la musique de louis jouvet comme s'il
était un petit peu l'héritier de douves
et de son talent alors que vous vous
l'avais joué 300 fois la porte sa marque
en trois ou quatre cent fois oui
donc ça vous choque un peu confiants
mais c'est parce que il est moi je les
aime beaucoup il a beaucoup de talent
mais ce n'est pas ce qu'on pourrait
croire il n'a peut-être pas assez de
mémoire
ouais tu comprends il en a dont jouit la
nabe jouer mais pour des difficultés ta
prestation tu veux dire ouais mais
facile mais c'est pas grave non c'est
grave enfin mis fin à tout casser
rectifier dans le livre c'est rectifié
puis surtout ce que vous dites c'est que
au sujet de louis jouvet cette fois non
plus de fabrice luchini
c'est michel serrault écrit que louis
jouvet était un excellent et d'amandes
comédiens personne va remettre 100
ingénia mais dès qu'ils se mettaient
louis jouvet à faire des analyses sur le
théâtre ce que fait un petit peu luchini
c'était de l'esbroufé en fait cette
façon d'intellectualiser le théâtre ça
vous énerve quoi on parle de deux jours
est qui était directeur de théâtre il
n'a jamais aussi bien joué la comédie
qu'au cinéma
ouais et alors il disait est ce parce
qu'aussi il avait beaucoup de il avait
c'est génial qui n'entrait pas à dire le
contraire magnifique
mais quand ont représenté avec 1000 il
avait horreur du cinéma avec ce que nous
connaissons moi je vais au théâtre
plusieurs fois j'ai vu deux fois dans ma
vie c'était magnifique 6 mai au cinéma
tout le monde connaît les prestations de
jouve est donc nommé lisais quand même
ça l'embêtait de d'admettre que le pool
à côté du théâtre y avait le cinéma où
il était génial
alors voilà alors bon alors je parle de
ça parce que je vous dis
j'espère qu'un jour fabrice luchini
redescendra à ma portée parce que si je
pouvais jouer avec lui qu'ils m'écoutent
oui j'aimerais bien parce que le le
principal pour un acteur je crois la
première chose c'est comme ce que nous
faisons en ce moment je me pose des
questions on y trouvera ses grands yeux
et les oreilles et tu m'écoutes oui et
moi j'essaie de répondre oui et en
diamant au théâtre c'est pareil dit
pardon qu'est ce que tu dis je parle et
tu me réponds vous trouvez en gros que
luchini manque d'humilité quoi c'est ça
non je crois qu'il a été mal élevés
n'ont pu alors michel serrault parle de
fabriquer et pia l'acteur qu'on ne peut
pas nommer par charité chrétienne ans il
se prend pour jean poiret qui limite
outrageusement premier pas deuxième
point ils jouent mal très mal même
troisième point mauvais esprits mauvaise
mine résume en quatrième point il donne
des leçons de morale à la terre entière
se dit humaniste mais n'oublie jamais
son intérêt personnel voilà dernier
point il est fait pour les tournées de
sous-préfecture où sa fausse élégance de
parvenus peut épater les casinos et
enfin il a un avis sur tout surtout dans
le sens du vent voilà mais qu'il est
habillé pour l'hiver la juste part du
cri vous parlez moi je sais très bien de
qui vous parlez
oui il nommait moi je pense avoir mais
je crois pas que ça puisse être lui
parce qu'il ya quand même des
contradictions
je crois qu'ils me disent à qui tu
penses il va
oui mais des choses qui ne collent pas
du tout alors si c est lui et si c'est
lui moi je pense michel pardon je pense
qu'il joue très bien la comédie mais bon
ouais c'est la seule chose où là je veux
dire la vérité les chefs monde pense à
pierre arditi en nous mais on se dit que
pierre arditi jeu vachement bien la
comédie donc comprendre non mais c'est
vrai quand tous les cas vous vous êtes
pas à contrairement à ce que vous dites
de ce comédien vous n'êtes pas dans le
sens du vent vous êtes plutôt les les
pieds dans le plat c'est le titre du
bouquin c'est l'utilisation qu'elles
justifient pas exempt titrait par
exemple vous ne comprenez pas moi je
trouve ça très bien de s'attaquer comme
ça aux vaches sacrées vous ne comprenez
pas très bien pourquoi tout le monde
adore jacques tati mais c'est pas ça
j'ai vu a fait une moue deux ne
s'étaient pas convaincant dans la
drôlerie
ouais il faudra mais là c'est mon nom
vous trouvez ça chiant vous endormez
devant la télé et je dis la suite et la
suite après oui mais quand c'est positif
veut pas nommer michel c'est vachement
bien que vous disiez ça moi je vous
savez je suis très bien où il ya une
espèce de consensus général national
c'est vachement bien qu'ils aient des
gens mais franchement victor hugo c'est
pas un peu de la merde écoute j'ai pas
lu alors pas dire vous n'êtes pas plus
tendre avec les hommes politiques en pas
la même et il veut mais je débite des
méchantes filles alors on va par un vous
dit raffarin quoi vous dites il est pas
antipathique raffarin on a un peu
l'impression vous dites qu'il tient la
boutique avant la fermeture c'est vrai
c'est vrai c'est le comique quoi
mais c'est pas méchant dont on parle des
commis de l'état lui c'est le cas mais
voilà il attend le patron alors là là où
ça va pas non là où ça va très bien
justement section des services publics
vous il faut que ça reste sous
l'autorité de l'état
je crois à ce que je pensais à ça un bon
jour je me disais mais pourquoi n'y
aurait pas une armée privée aussi il y
en a en irak on voit ce que ça donnerait
voilà c'est à dire la prison d'abou
ghraïb en irak voilà alors vous parlez
aussi des intermittents du spectacle
michel serrault vous dit un truc vrai
vous dites les intermittents du
spectacle c'est une appellation
épouvantable il faut il devrait déjà
manifestés pour on les appelle
différemment parce qu'un intermittent du
spectacle c'est vrai que c'est un terme
un peu un peu hard hausse et alors
effectivement vous dit les choses parce
que voilà vous dit
certains figurants de cinéma refuse de
tourner trois jours pour ne pas perdre
leur assedic
voilà là on en parle d'une chose très
délicate et de l'ain difficile c'est pas
grave c'est des choses qui m'a qui
m'étonne toujours tu vois tant mieux
qu'on ce que de la culture et qu'on
donne la possibilité à tout le monde
mais qu'un mec qui vient à lui mais une
arrêt choix gaz dans un film devient
intermittent du spectacle
là il ya un abus quelque part qu'est ce
que vous dites de 2 du peintre oui qu'il
était chez lui qui peint est quelqu'un
qui vend pas ses toiles
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire je demande ce
qu'il faut faire il ya il ya quand même
des critères et il ya des métiers à
risques j'ai eu mon pantalon troué
jusqu'à 25 ans tu comprends je veux des
jugements vous dites il faut accepter le
risque inévitable du métier d'artiste
savez que c'est pas un métier très sûr
c'est ce qu'on me dise ailleurs le
compositeur qui ne vend pas c'est que
c'est au qatar
qu'est ce qui va faire le port est bon
alors moi je voudrais aussi qu'on
s'occupe de lui un et puis on verrait
les partitions puis on essaierait de le
faire manger aussi et le compositeur et
le peintre et le et l'architecte qui
vend pas ses plans etc etc
donc il ya une grande confusion là
dedans
et que perche alors tout le monde noie
le poisson personnes sans temps et je te
gred et je te crève pas et vivent ceux
ci vivent cela moins minable
ouais alors ceci étant michel serrault
vous êtes extrêmement solidaires des
victimes des injustices vous dites
suis-je de droite
suis-je de gauche oui effectivement à
l'église de droite je préfère l'église
de gauche mais votre véritable
dichotomie à vous elle s'opère entre
croyants et incroyants dans un premier
temps plutôt contre gauche et droite et
et vous dites il faut être du côté des
pauvres
voilà ça c'est la seule chose finalement
qui doit nous mener occupons nous des
gens qu'on rencontre dans la vie on
n'aura pas besoin de s'expatrier très
loin pour de service alors simplement
ouvrons nos oreilles nos yeux et puis
ouvrons notre bourse
et puis essayons de faire quelque chose
mais le reste tout le reste ça m'a et
reste pas beaucoup
d'ailleurs vous dit un truc formidable
dit un athée solidaire vaut mieux qu un
catho qui fait rien pour les autres
ben oui ça me parait commençons pas à
ces critères et puis après ça bon on ira
peut-être vers autre chose mais ne
commencez pas par le bon dieu ne parlait
pas du bon dieu
les âges il faut faire des actes si vous
pouvez aider quelqu'un à côté de chez
vous ou en lozère ou n'importe où voilà
c'est pas mêler les grandes idées n'ont
commencé par sortir des soutes votre
poche pour les autres vous êtes un vrai
chrétien vous je suis pas un vrai
chrétien je crois que sans parler mais
j'aime pas beaucoup qu'on m'accuse
d'être chrétien je suis pas un exemple
j'suis pas mais je crois que tout toutes
les croyances commence par l'espèce
d'humanité et de fraternité avec les
gens et basta le reste on verra après
[Applaudissements]
michel serres il était ici les pieds
dans le plat mes pieds dans le plat en
pieds dans le plat c'est le titre du
livre vous parlez de moi dans votre
bouquin n'ont pas de trace ici ça oblige
à vous vous dites thierry ardisson je le
préfère dans rive droite rive gauche que
dans tout le monde en parle
thierry ardisson c'est docteur jekyll et
mister hyde
c'est triste de le voir ainsi s'abîmer
vous parler de ce que je fais dans cette
émission c'est triste de le voir ainsi
s'abîmer c'est terrible ça que vous
disiez des choses comme ça à michel je
suis le même dans les deux emissions
mais voir quelqu'un que j'ai c'est pas
terrible parce que j allais il y en a
une il ya 4 millions de gens et l'auto
ya deux cent mille personnes c'est tout
on peut pas faire la même chose vous qui
êtes un homme de spectacle c'est bien
qu'on peut pas faire la même chose pour
deux cent mille personnes ou pour 4
millions de gens et c'est ça qu'il faut
faire pour temps mais y aurait jamais
quelque chose il faut vous qu'on gérait
la croûte offert comme ça à tous publics
et c'est oui on essaye mais voilà les
jeudis des choses aimables quand même à
vous dit à la fin de quoi je me mêle ce
qu'il a de mieux à mon écoute je dirais
que ce livre il est fait pour rire
sérieusement oui et puis basta le rail
ce serait très bien votre bouquin parce
que juste après m'avoir dit que j'étais
docteur jeckyll et mister hype oui vous
vous attaquez fogiel
donc ça c'est formidable j'attaque sur
brigitte bardot ah oui j'aime pas parce
que j'aime beaucoup brigitte bardot
ouais comme j'ai plus vingt ans j'ai
commencé avec elle à jouer la comédie et
je les aime beaucoup et je l'admirais
beaucoup comme comédienne comme
chanteuse comme femme magnifique
la belle est maintenant alors on s'amuse
et on fin du scandale autour d'elle les
animaux et qu'elle s'occupe des animaux
commencer si vous n'avez pas le courage
de
deux de vous occuper des autres prenez
exemple sur bardon et commencé de d'être
bon avec les ânes à mon avis et vous
verrez qu'un jour vous vous intéresserez
aux autres ou semaine aux hommes aux
femmes et aux enfants
donc alors basta pas de pas de
changement rochelle ce que vous dites ce
qu'ils ont manipulé pour l'amener sur le
plateau voilà avec une fois quel a été
son plateau de l'ont massacré voilà
qu'est ce que vous essayez de faire avec
moi
la première celle là ça c'est la
mastercard
le must d'accord ou demandeurs des trois
marques vous dites vous dites encore des
choses à vous dire plein de trucs nom
vous dit vous dites que fogiel étaient
moins arrogant avec de longs parce que
delon l'aurait sûrement pas supporté je
pense qu'il ya de ça mais moi je dois y
aller chez lui mais j'y vais pas je dois
bouger mieux venir ici parce que là on
se comprend
[Musique]
c'est bien
alors comme vous avez dit que cette
émission était parfois nul
vous allez avoir droit michel serrault à
une interview nul
[Musique]
michel serrault vous devez partir
vous devez partir jelle serreau je dois
parties devaient partir trois ans ou
alors tu me croisant dans un vaisseau
spatial avec quelqu'un vous êtes deux
dans ce vaisseau spatial vous devez
partir est ce que vous choisissez
thierry ardisson marc olivier fogiel ou
co et trois ans dans le vaisseau spatial
je crois que je t'emmène ces gentilles
nom mail valide l'essai de deux points
c'est un peu les gens pour que cette
soirée où cette émission est un peu de
piment et c'est normal est anormal mais
tu sais ce que tu as à tes un bon fond
c'est vrai c'est vrai tu n'es pas
méchant mais c'est bien que tu t'en
quelquefois un peu bête mais
michel est ce que vous préférez être
peint ces mordus ou pic et pic et je le
suis donc ça ex que vous accepteriez
d'échanger une paralysie générale contre
la fin définitive des inondations au
bangladesh paralysie générale aux gens
c'est l'inde qui montre la fin des
inondations bangladesh en même temps ben
voui voui c'est intéressant je veux
sauver des vies il faut que je consulte
un avocat tu seras paralysé jusqu'à la
fin de tes jours ne faisiez pas tous des
jeunes écoutent franchement de mentir
pour l'eau aujourd'hui un style jazzy je
peux pas te répondrais je comprends
quand j'irai un peu moins bien plus te
dira et allons-y
[Applaudissements]
si vous disparaissez messieurs 0 acquis
confieriez-vous votre enfant à fabrice
luchini ou à pierre arditi jeu au couple
il car ils sont vraiment beaucoup
vous avez commis un crime à qui demander
vous de cacher le corps
osant d'armes avril sur aux gendarmes et
aux parents quel est l'animal qui
embrasse le mieux michel la limace
michel serrault est-ce que vous
préféreriez mourir tout de suite là
maintenant et aller au paradis ou vivre
trente ans de plus et alors d'en faire
en je crois que je l'aï question
intéressante
vas-y on est tous les deux dans un
chalet à la neige en quelle horreur il
fait pas toi la mer et il fait très
froid on ne peut pas sortir du chalet on
n'a plus rien à manger
oui vous êtes obligé de me manger vous
commencez par quelles parties de mon
corps fait part ce soit plus simple sans
livrer un peu de fond de teint
bien souvent des effectivement il est
encore plus bête non alors que vous
préférez oui un président de la
république d'extrême droite élu au
suffrage universel ou pas d'élection du
tout je pense que les c il n'y a pas de
choix parce que c'est pareil pouvait
lire ou laisser faire les choses
je pense qu'ils ont le même résultat
michel serrault me sentir très bon ça
moi michel serrault aimeriez-vous avoir
année supplémentaire oui un oeil
supplémentaires un doigt supplémentaire
ou un sexe et supplémentaires en fait
embêté parce que je pensais que tu
verras après mais ça peut servir non non
ce qui m'embête c'est avec son doigt l'a
carrément à doigts dans le nez c'est pas
très joli comme une question c'est quand
même il n'aurait pas fait ça avec aulas
il avait un col romain il c'était autre
chose
non mais de la tenue et maintenant c'est
la débandade
dernière question la plus importante
michel serrault oui vous laver les
cheveux tous les combien
eh ben ça va tu es toni pourrait être
deux fois par jour non
je
c'est ans
alors
et là
seul cet accord
[Applaudissements]
ça
voici vanessa paradis
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
bon
c'est vous
c'est vrai que ça faisait un moment
certains moments qu'on n'avait pas vu
une vanessa paradis
on est très heureux très heureux de
pouvoir donner ça alors lors de notre
première rencontre c'était en 1987
c'était aux bains douches l'émission
s'appelait bain de minuit
c'était l'année de joe le taxi et les
paroles de la chanson était d' etienne
roda-gil magnéto serge alors la petite
fille vanessa comet a vendu des spatules
c'est non pas loin d'un million de ces
quelques clins d'oeil le lier aux
valeurs de ce moment
après chaque mois 20 ans tu peux le
chantait joe fake six ans
tu vas pas de chanter en espagnol si je
chante un stadium est passé ça ce soir
voilà c'est fait diminuer en 1985 avec
julien clerc etienne roda-gil vanessa
paradis
étienne roda-gil qui nous a quittés
récemment et pour qui je voudrais qu'on
est une une pensée parce que c'est
quelqu'un de tout à fait important pour
nous et et pour vous regard du commun
vraiment un type exceptionnel
on l'a pas dit ici au moment où nous ça
s'est passé parce que c'était comme ça
et ce soir je suis ravi de lui rendre
hommage en votre compagnie vanessa
etienne
si tu ne regardes comme d'une rigueur
juridique et regarde arte qui les
tiennent
ouais ah oui bien sûr il arrive ce soir
vanessa après cinq ans d'absence cinéma
donc le temps de faire deux enfants lily
rose et jack le temps d'un cd qui
s'appelle bliss et d'une tournée vous
revenez dans un film absolument barjots
une comédie de science-fiction qui
s'appelle atomik circus le retour de
james bataille des frères poireau alors
c'est un film ovni ascain c'est
complètement un pitch à bhl c'est une
série z déjanté ça se passe dans un
village qui s'appelle scott lake city un
village rétro-futuriste donc au fin fond
des usa où on prépare une grande fête
c'est la fête de la tarte à la vache
avec une chanteuse qui s'appelle quantya
c'est vous et un cascadeur qui s'appelle
james se bataillent voilà alors dès son
arrivée james e bataille séduit concha
qui veut devenir chanteuse
poussé par son père le patron du bar qui
est joué par jean-pierre marielle voilà
mais la fête se termine en catastrophe à
paris et parallèlement un météorite
s'écrase sur scott let libérant
d'étranges choses volante gens les
pieuvres des pierres volante avait comme
dans les films américains des années 50
et la débarque
l'imprésario alan chiasse joué par
benoît poelvoorde
qui drague vannes et cela c'est un pitch
assez bien ce que je disais c'est la
vigne est ce que je propose d'abord
avant toute chose
ben et ça c'est que vous regardiez votre
caméra et que vous dites magnéto serge
on va voir à quoi ça ressemble ici
merci mais je ne me suis pas présentée
fiasse alan chiasse un imprésario
je suis la recherche une jeune chanteuse
comme il ya konan comme cha cha
voilà la connaissez c'est incroyable
c'est ma fille
de winne qui est là aujourd'hui et qui
j'avais levé une honnête monsieur chier
venu tout droit de la villette a tant
séduit lors si c'est dur à série
[Musique]
des halles est absent sur le leap x lion
et dégage vous êtes comme shia au mourre
dieu quelle méprise
excusez moi je jouerai plus pour la
boniche comment un chien chien à tous
avec de neuf mois
moines et sa part indiqué notre invité
ce soir voilà sorti le 21 juillet c'est
insensé ce film quand vous avez reçu le
scénario vous avez réagi comme en ait
beaucoup ri ouais beaucoup risquent pas
essayer de remettre les pages dans
l'ordre c'est vrai qu'ils avaient pas
mal des choses incompréhensibles et
enfin des choses pas très claires mais
il y avait un ton qui a dans le film
était déjà dans le scénario le la bande
démo des frères poro qui avait fait
beaucoup de pub et des courts métrages
des clips étaient vraiment un sens c'est
très très très original et puis eux
c'est des garçons bourré talent est
tellement sincère et je suis très fier
d'être de faire partie de ce film qui a
été fait en france 20 des français avec
des acteurs presque tous français et
vash est fier alors les frères poireau
effectivement ce sont des 91 1
ils ont fait appel pour la musique à
d'autres nantais qui s'appelle les
petits lapins des little rabbits il ya
une chanson qui est très drôle c'est la
pétroleuse
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien
yolande orlando nous lui parlons nous il
n'ya pas d'autre marché l'année
prochaine non plus la hollande où il
commença bien casser les couilles quand
même bon orlando exige le clip ma m 20
[Musique]
map être le faire
ouais ouais
dany c'est un paradis avec des petits
lapins
ça s'appelle matt et alors
[Applaudissements]
vous allez me kamerhe
étonnant
je tiens à beni hssen
que trois mois
pourquoi
3 kerry ça arrive parfois je crois que
les gens le public n'accroche pas que
cette chanson non
c'est pas la peine de s'acharner on aime
être à plus tard j'aime la chanson c'est
comme ça qu'est ce que tu veux pas
laisser les gens droit de le faire alors
le disque sort chez barclays ce qui veut
dire que contrairement aux rumeurs qui
ont couru
vous n'êtes pas viré de chez barclays
ils ont fait d'autres chez barclays
ouais
ceci étant en ce moment vous le semblait
préférer vanessa paradis votre carrière
d'actrice à votre carrière de chanteuse
8 le cinéma c'est les vacances de la
personnalité on devient quelqu'un
d'autre on est très entourée c'est vrai
alors que je sens un peu c'est d'une
extrême solitude
non mais en plus je préfère pas je
préfère passer c'est le les projets
l'avion que ça ça se présente comme ça
et puis je met plus de temps à faire les
chansons maintenant parce que je les
fais un petit peu moins avec l'aide
d'autres personnes et donc ça me prend
le temps ce que j'essayerai facture icc
l'on vous dit je ne suis pas gainsbourg
et puis les enfants prennent beaucoup de
temps
c'est moi qui vais prendre beaucoup de
temps avec mes enfants parce que je n'ai
rien envie de louper c'est à vous les
élevez vous même quoi a pas je suis déjà
allé faire élever par d'autres préfèrent
les élevez vous même les pauvres
alors question cinéma quand même vous
venez de tourner avec le scénariste de
la fille sur le pont qui s'appelle
manqué qui a réalisé son premier film
away est un petit bijou et c'est encore
quelqu'un que j'aime beaucoup qui a
écrit acquis écrit une histoire sublimer
je viens juste de finir de le tourner
donc c'est encore assez frais avec un
jeune acteur qui s'appelle vincent
rottiers il faut retenir son nom parce
que c'est une oeuvre une bombe atomique
une paire la règle à 17 ans et c est ce
que tu es à son portable à vincent
rottiers un attaché de presse
on va demander qu'il appelle pour nous
d'inviter tout de suite oui alors en
tous les cas ce qu'on peut dire vanessa
c'est vous fait pas d'effort particulier
pour tournée en amérique vous dj aucune
ambition internationale vous ai même pas
d'agent hollywood
non non non pourquoi mais parce que j'ai
enfin ils ont déjà ils ont des gens très
très bien ils ont pas franchement besoin
de nous croient qu'ils ont besoin nous a
pas moins que ce soit un projet enfin
quelque chose de spécial mais faire la
course au projet un poisson faut tout le
temps être leur moi qui tourne quand
même une fois tous les 36 du mois la
main il faudrait tourner tout lente ou
le temps pour jamais qu on vous oublie
pied parce que je franchement j'ai eu
moi j'ai tout ce qu'il me faut ici en
france puis j'ai un peu plus l'europe
pourquoi je voyage je n'ai pas déjà ça
me prend beaucoup de temps
s'il fallait en plus que je fasse ça là
bas puis c'est bien là bas on ne montre
pas du doigt
si vous êtes sages finalement non je
sais pas ouais si voici maintenant elle
élève ses enfants elle veut pas faire la
course à hollywood
vous êtes assez sage moi je suis très
normal c'est très ennuyeux c'est bien
non pas du tout enfin je sais pas ce
qu'en pense votre johnny depp mais moi
personnellement je trouve ça bien de se
plaindre
apparemment fait longtemps que cet
enfant ne suis quand même temps si c'est
bien déjà et vous michel depuis quand
même temps et votre femme
trois mois alors c'est facile
demain nous à savoir que commencer les
trois premiers mois c'est les plus durs
visuel mais vivent ensemble depuis trois
mois
wissam pas marié encore un trois mois et
les noces de bistrot vanessa est
toujours pas mariés n'ont plus jamais ça
j'ai des enfants alors vanessa vous
n'avez toujours pas de projet avec
johnny depp qui a eu cette histoire de
don quichotte pour laquelle nous avons
reçu jean rochefort ici l'année dernière
pour la sortie du dvd bon aventure
avortée terrible histoire évidemment et
c'est vrai qu'après le succès de pirates
des caraïbes qui a fait quand même 621
millions de dollars de recettes énormes
la suite est déjà en chantier donc vivre
là il est happé par sa est en fait
effectivement vous concentrer sur votre
rôle de maman surtout à los angeles où
vous passez votre temps entre les cours
de danse pour les enfants les ateliers
d'arts plastiques pour les enfants
le pédiatre pour les enfants et leurs
parents les enfants et un poney club là
bas mais c'est bien tout le monde sait
pas si vous preniez de la coke au queen
tous les soirs on vous félicite pas
voilà maintenant alors entre deux
tournages vous avez votre maison avec
johnny depp dans le sud de la france
nous reposer un petit peu voilà la drees
qui passe
les déviations d'accès pour 19,4 demande
alors vous dites on va au marché en
cuisinant mangent ils ont une vie encore
terriblement simple vous vivez une
espèce de bohème très chic un petit peu
comme dans les années soixante dix les
rockstars d'idées comme ça quand vous
voyagez avec johnny depp j'ai quand même
30 valise qui vous suivent que j'ai
quand même c'est pas d'arriver par
ailleurs voyages vous savez celle aussi
où il ya des freins les meubles non par
exemple gt2 un exemple oran le drap qui
recouvre la table à langer par les
enfants soient habitués à la couleur du
drap vanessa prend ce drap tu en voilà
c'est tout ça c'est vrai ah c'est beau
quand vous dites ça mais non mais aussi
parce que moi j'en les enfants et vivent
une vie de bohème eux au fond c'est vrai
qu'on leur a pas tellement de demander
leur avis ne sont pas l'air de s'en
plaindre mais il faut quand même pas les
jeux l'échangé de maison sans arrêt sans
qu'ils aient des choses aussi qui
reconnaissent qu'on a pour patron
vanessa paradis et johnny depp ch et un
couple parfait
c'est le bonheur absolu donc on va faire
une interview je fous la merde
[Musique]
message est toujours amoureuse de johnny
depp n'est toujours pas mariés donc vous
serez pas qu'il est un peu moins bon ce
moment site il faut non c'est vrai qu'il
a une vilaine verrues plantaires
c'est pas dommage d'être tout le temps
séparés dans le sérieux justement n'a
pas tout le temps c'est vrai vous
néglige pas là non non c'est caen qui
vous a dit je t'aime pour la dernière
fois vous avez cadeau qui vous a fait
c'est quoi
vale est vachement attentionné quand ils
offrent des fleurs il dit pas sa
secrétaire de le faire c'est lui qui va
vraiment les achetés au magasin il
n'oublie jamais votre anniversaire
tu veux de votre rencontre non plus non
merci l'internet pour savoir si les
parcelles moi je vous le confirme tout
de suite et il est parfait
vous engueuler parfois quand même bien
sûr qu'il est parfait il oublie de
relever la cuvette des toilettes
non jamais non c'est un mec ranger câble
non sérieusement c'est quoi qui vous
énerve le plus chez lui qu'on le fasse
pas nous il a des défauts mais je
voulais mais alors il est pardonné il
laisse traîner ses chaussettes
bah ouais mais j'aimerais pas qui
arrange tout c'est à grabo énorme effet
si vous êtes folle de lui on va dire il
a un petit peu un tempérament de feu
ouais et qui sait pas toujours très
facile mais moi ça me plaît à ceux qui à
l'eau bassan routier sa bulle c'est
laurent bâti tué sur paris là il peut
passer
oui bonjour vincent 20 tonnes qui on est
à l'antenne tu es sur paris est ce que
tu peux passer s'il te plaît à la plaine
saint denis
c'est vanessa nadine ans et vanessa
paradis qui a parlé de toi la dictée
était formidable et je te la pastèque
man toile qu on t'attend
moi aussi je t'embrasse je te passe
vanessa à l'eau non mais si toi
non mais c'est mais ouais mais je n'y
suis pour rien j'ai juste voulu dire des
jeux d'hiver alors alors quand en plus
c'est un gilet de venir mais non ils
veulent que tu n'en vient pas du refah
version de l'état
[Applaudissements]
mon ange wen avait ya plein mon nom mais
il a mieux à faire il à la fête de la
musique c'est ça c'est bien cette
semaine tandis que la faille à l'aide de
papa moss de lui même et j'ai beaucoup
de tendresse pour les jeux la date
d'arrivée ça bien et c'est ainsi pas
sonné samedi a pu la fête de la musique
celle dans la peau qui viennent allez
allez vanessa elle tu adores jusqu'à
johnny depp jeu serait jaloux mois elle
cadors elle a vite à 18 balles étaient
hyper mignon à la dynamo il venait
d'avoir 18 ans elle a même chanté enfin
il vit que c'est une belle aventure avec
toi mais qui passe de minutes à nous
raconter bon en tout cas là on t'attend
je crois qu'il a passés que de mettre
les choses au point
alors
2 deux trois petites questions diva donc
il est parfait c'est johnny depp
évidemment il râle pas quand il faut
descendre la poubelle non mais rallye
il a dès ma vie qui vous énerve quand
même oh là là quand même bien a quand
même à vous l'avez déjà chopé en train
de regarder un film porno non non bon
ben c'est sans espoir
les yeux
j'accueille maintenant patrick timsit et
l'en but
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
catherine team six noms
mais
comment ça va
il est ici pour l'américain dans les
mines au film de patrick timsit avec
thierry lhermitte emilie dequenne
richard berry marianne denicourt et
lorànt deutsch
sortie le 7 juillet je faire le pitch ah
oui voir si j'y arrive et on va voir si
je comprends oui alors c'est l'histoire
d'un mec persuadé qu'il est américain et
qui comprend pas pourquoi il n'a pas le
droit de vivre dans le pays qu'il aime
voilà c'est un jeu très claires
non c'est très bien c'est très bien
alors là c'est pas drôle mais c'est très
bien mais ça c'est le pitch alors ils
pensent américains y mange américain il
vit américain mais il est français marie
les chiens américains là et il est année
au bon endroit il est né ici et thierry
lhermitte la semaine dernière parlé du
film et il disait que finalement c'est
un peu comme un mec qui est persuadé
d'être une femme dans un corps d'homme
enfin un transsexuel il le dit
d'ailleurs montré moins chier si je
voulais changer de sexe ça veut dire que
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui vouloir être
américain quand on sait quand on est
français on a le droit de se sentir
américain vouloir c'est la liberté de
circulation c'est pourquoi on est né
quelque part on doit y rester
voilà voilà donc c'est un peu c'est le
sujet du film ça alors lorànt deutsch
dans le film donc grâce à l'avocat
thierry lhermitte va réussir à inquiéter
les états unis et a créé un 51e état du
côté de merl est là c'est un peu comme
si le village d'astérix demander son
rattachement à rome quoi oui c'est le
village assez rythmé il veut être romain
quoi un village 1 1 voilà qu'en début de
promo non non non enfin le moment j'ai
déjà 8 non au milieu de la promo à mon
sens déjà y en a plein le cul de parler
de ton
on m'a donné un sens c'est vous qui êtes
protéger leur sphère énergiquement allez
allez vas-y la patate
thierry périssé la pratique bordel là
qu'ils allaient donc c'est l'histoire
d'un mec qui est persuadé qu'il est rien
et il comprend pas pourquoi il n'a pas
le droit de vivre dans le pays qu'il
aime aux américains ils mangent america
mais sylvie américain mais lui français
jamais au bon endroit voilà mais grâce à
un avocat cynique et froid qui s'appelle
thierry lhermitte
ils vont réussir à inquiéter états unis
en décrétant les merlettes 51e état des
états unis voilà c'est un peu comme si
le village d'astérix demander son
rattachement à en famille non
c'est
et
nous en forme que jamais à temps ah non
vous êtes en forme pour des gains
illicites a mis là à temps c'est bien
filmé et bien il peut faire beaucoup
mieux il y en a beaucoup plus sous le
capot il va te prouver allez donc c'est
l'histoire d'un mec est persuadé qu'il
est rien et il comprend pas pourquoi il
n'a pas le droit de vivre dans le pays
latino américains à limoges américain
levi américain mais les pensées allaient
aux balles endroit là mais grâce à un
avocat cynique est toi qui s'appelle
thierry derby ils vont réussir à quitter
les états unis
en décrétant les merlettes 51e état des
états unis à certains comme si le
village d'astérix demander son
rattachement au nom de ce qu'ils voient
il est là bas parce qu'ils me parlent in
ou pas ce qu'on peut dire c'est qu'ils
voient l'américain peu comme les
immigrants du xviiie un peu comme
l'eldorado
bien sûr ben oui [ __ ] les pertes que
je m'étends mais prend les meilleurs
chez lui nous dire bah il a bien pris
l'habitude de faire de la télé c'est
qu'avant il va la télé tous les jours
avant que la tous les jours et la faim
tu me semble moins professionnel c'est
ce que je voudrais faire
non mais c'est pas ça situe à la perche
je tend des perches que ce pas il aime
pas l'amérique pour se caler pour ce
qu'elle représente exactement c'est en
amérique c'est l'amérique du
divertissement le coca cola c'est peter
pas en quoi c'est d'ailleurs que son
america lui c'est un peu comme un monde
imaginaire à monde perdue qui existe
plus que qui est plus comme il l'est il
s'attend à voir john wayne déboulé au
coin d'une rue pour sauver la veuve et
l'orphelin et il s'en fout de savoir ce
qui se passait tout le contexte un petit
peu difficile aujourd'hui que quand que
qu'englobe l'amérique lui pour lui c'est
pas du tout ce à quoi s'est vraiment
l'amérique d'hollywood de la dernière
séance qui aimait le cinéma a fermé
aujourd'hui
élue d'un boulet à traîner quitté trois
quarts garde trop téléphone au curragh
alors ce que je peux faire ça va nous
faire un break oui c'est moi pendant que
laurent téléphone
vous avez gardé votre caméra vous n'êtes
pas mais aussi après attention à 2h12
met trois ans aucun mal et au ch de
votre démarche me suis fan
c'est pour avoir la nationalité
américaine je suis obligé de vous
décourager
je pense à quelqu'un je bouffe américain
alors je mets rien faut se rendre à
l'évidence pour vos parents qui sont
avérées témoins à mon père était
français
mais ma mère était française aussi
d'ailleurs
jen n'a pas besoin d'un avocat
à leur grande gueule l'arrogant ya pas
plus français que vous
et puis dans la course edwards on sait
par une meilleure idée si j'obtiens
francis farges nationalité américaine
c'est moi qui vous rachète on parie aux
américains c'est quoi un frigo de
français pur porc sacs poubelles vous
voulez venir américain pakistanais
demain c'est une notice manqué la
supplier de nous suivre
on va former une équipe de football
américain - les américains je suis pour
eux fbi fausses bonnes idées comme je
laisse american gods and america blesse
en trempant d'entropa monde battus pour
entrer chez toi à pourvoir bien seul
effet du bas et développer tous en haut
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi ce board cptaq en profite
melita dépôt de saucisson sur les yeux
ou arrête avec ça on n'y est pas la
différence entre un fou et moi c'est que
moi je suis pas fou on y évoque alors un
petit examen
oui bah non ça suffit en permanence et
au niveau langue à nouveau langues
il a les bases mais pas les bonnes ces
phoques tous les trois mots seule chine
red state of grace ce qui veut dire qu
en tournée dans le cul
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le banc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
persuadé colorier joe dassin l'amérique
l'amérique c'est bizarre je me sentir
dans le taxi déjà ils ont fait une bo
avec aia on s'attendait pas c'est moi la
musique très mal en point g
c'est bien si on pouvait faire ça
oui
[Musique]
hu
c
m
[Musique]
dans l'année
akhenaton faf larage toile américain
bande originale du film de parier sur le
coup voilà c'est moins fort que joe
dassin qui veut dire patrick timsit
c'est que l'américain le scénario
s'inspire de faits réels de votre vie
parce que depuis l'âge de 14 15 ans vous
avez vécu ce rêve américain daily
régulièrement aux états unis et vous
aviez une idée monde votre adolescence
qui était d'importer des skate board et
d'exporter de la ratatouille
voilà c'est vrai qu'on allait
régulièrement avec des potes aux états
unis qu'on avait ce rêve américain là
bas tout est possible une idée un dollar
et c'est possible et donc c'est vrai
qu'on ya cru et que et qu'on n'y était
tous les jours à chercher donc des idées
à un moment on était la croissanterie
est la dernière idée c'était la
ratatouille j'étais avec fabrice nataf
mon copain ex patron de virgin
voilà qui est aujourd'hui celle du bail
et tout y est on se réunissait aux idées
ont pas on part en juin comparé aux
conjoints avec les bocaux dont on allait
la fabriquer là-bas on s'est arrêté
fabrique ennahda avait oui sentent
français du commerce extérieur on était
en quarts et surtout on était un peu
pointu adacore oui avec les berrer
maurice chevalier dans le jukebox on va
faire un bar français qu'on va appeler
la ratatouille et mon rêve américain
s'est arrêtée de là où le film commence
c'est à dire que francis farges peut
manger quand vous allez chercher le visa
quoi oui exactement on se retrouve place
de la concorde au au consulat d'amérique
et on dit bah voilà on a une idée on
voudrait oui quoi et moi on voudrait
exporter la ratatouille on voudrait
vivre là-bas très bien c'est possible
oui c'est possible
vous avez un père américain et d'une
mère américaine non un frère une soeur
peut-être non un parent proche non vous
êtes marié à une américaine non c'est
pas possible alors et voilà on s'est
retrouvés un après midi de juin place de
la concurrence a erré comme comme
francis fages dans le film et on avait
perdu notre rêve américain quoi parce
que ça va mais çà mau qui vivait à los
angeles souvent est ce qu'on trouve de
la ratatouille
tu vois là donc voilà jamais personne
mais le maire disait pas mentent jamais
personne ne l'a fait mais là ça va
donner des idées ya des gens qui vont
déposer le brevet datant les les
croissances apparaissait aussi qu
aujourd'hui à plein de croissanterie
ouais c'est impressionnant oui voyez du
malade
non mais tu aurais fait fortune tenter
de gagner plus devenu qu'avec le cinéma
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui je vendrai
de la ratatouille à los angeles
destin qu'il faut choisir alors c'est un
enjeu n'est sortie de ce film pour vous
en êtes stressé un peu pas très bien la
patte avec salut alors pas du tout mais
pas du tout pas du tout pas du tout
stressé
prenez des risques la grève n'ont aucun
m'a dit une fois une phrase génial il ya
beaucoup de risques à ne pas prendre de
risques
ah oui exactement alors je maintiens
c'est vrai que tant qu'on croit qu'on
est dans le risque on prend moins de
risques quand on pense qu'il ya pas de
risque à la
et puis non il ya un proverbe génial
c'est les bateaux sont à l'abri dans les
ports mais ne sont pas fait pour cela
ah ça reste valable pour moi absolument
je préfère casser en mer que de rester
au port il ya un risque que vous pouvez
plus en tous les cas c'est celui de
venir sur les plateaux télé quoi on vous
voit plus ouais tiens au début de votre
carrière du titre est généreux avec la
télé vous étiez là j'ai marc et moi la
première fois que j'ai eu un fou rire
sur un plateau de télé c'est un double
jeu avec patrick il y avait les noirs
qui tenaient les hallebardes comme ça
ils leur toucher des couilles et c'est
la première fois où je me suis marré je
me suis dit là mais je me suis dit je me
suis dit mais c'est un boulot on peut
rire en le faisant parce que jusque là
je faisais quand même encore plus
sérieusement que maintenant et je me
suis dit on peut rire en le faisant
et ça a été vraiment pour moi une
révélation cette émission et depuis on
vous a plus jamais beaucoup vu mais
alors est ce que c'est moi qui ai changé
ou la télé qui a changé non c'est vous
parce que vous c'est vous bon si je vais
vous dire d'un triptyque patrick
connaissais pas avant ses chances avec
20 minutes et l'affiché les couilles de
personnes
non c'est avec amour et patrick amand
vous étiez profession invités c'est vrai
vous dites les gens pensent que je fais
que invité à la télé donc est ce que je
faisais à côté donc je vais faire autre
chose et ils vous allez rompu
complètement les ponts avec la télé trop
parce qu'il n'est pas question non plus
de venir soient tous les jours soit
jamais donc là vous avez commencé à plus
jamais venir
il ya eu une rupture d'affectivité avec
le public vous le savez ça avec avec le
public télé voulait dire non le public
en général le public en ont peut-être
pas si si si si le public a cru que vous
le voulez ce mobile parce que fogiel
n'est pas là qu'il faut prendre sa place
ce n'est pas l'or est resté lui même un
réseau du club camille miceli gens
venant mais de façon à oui c'est ça je
sens non je sens qu'ils n'ont pas
déconner avec moi non c'est sérieux
c'est qu'on est passé à changer parce
que vous nous manquiez avec plaisir à 6
et une déclaration d'amour là si je
viens c'est bien sûr c'est ça
c'est la grande réconciliation sociale
non mais c'est comme ça je prends bien
mon nom mais ça n'est que ça ça mais que
ça ok vous avez peur de quoi en menant à
la télé de vous banalisez de vous tous
qui est rare est précieux il a raison de
se protéger
vous êtes bien de quoi il suffisait aux
concours vous avez peur d'un dérapage a
pas du tout certain du dérapage puisque
en général c'est moi qui les provoque
c'est pas du gpat eut donné vous n'êtes
pas peur de déraper oui mais dieudonné
dérape pas hanter les idées à entre les
télés donnez moi j'ai jamais vu qu'il
avait dérapé en télé j'ai vu quelqu'un
qui l'a fait déraper en télé votre avis
quand il s'appelle maintenant cinq ans
un bouquin de michel non mais c'est vrai
père de quoi faisait pas peur de déraper
bouger sa part ce départ mais j'ai peur
de ne plus rien avoir à raconter j'aime
bien venir ici avant la patate
et puis tout d'un coup un peu
déstabilisé avoir des choses à si vous
en fais tous les jours vous vous répétez
il ya un truc et vous devenez bon client
est bon client de quoi qu'est-ce que
alors laurent l'europe est ce que vous
êtes heureux vous de faire de la télé
devenir la télé oui ça va c'est sa façon
vous dit que ce sera toujours plus grave
que le métier de votre père ouais ben
forcément et on a moins les doigts dans
la merde
ouais il est plombier mais on n'est pas
obligé des bouchers des trucs donc c'est
forcément quelque chose de de plus
gratifiant même si c'est un métier qui
est qui est très nécessaire et surtout
en ce moment où l'on chauffe eau à péter
on les sait bien les cordonniers les
moyens chaussée parce que j'ai envie de
faire une annonce pour mon père
si tu pouvais venir la semaine prochaine
ce serait bien si je commence vraiment à
en avoir marre
un chauffe eau chaude 100 litres je peux
pas le sortir tout seul j'ai encore
plein de rêves à bayeux heureusement
vous marier et faire l'amour déjà fait
pousser le fait nous a raconté déjà
compter les pendentifs en fusion la cie
sa poupée un énorme bateau s'est passé
quel genre d'homme gens ne plus chercher
dans n'importe laquelle une consentants
ouais déjà et non non je crois que j'ai
trouvé un way et je suis très épris jeu
sous le patrick avec ça en permanence
donc voilà vous êtes sur une bonne piste
savaria pas vous êtes autonome dans ses
maîtresses et prix malheureusement je ne
crois pas que ce soit pas forcément
partagé mais à mais on est plein de
rêves
donc on bosse et puis les le principal
dans un rêve c'est pas forcément d'y
arriver mais c'est de courir pour
l'atteindre et je sais que vous avez le
prix jean gabin
ouais j'ai peut-être dû lui dire là
peut-être dû le savoir mais ça n'allait
pas trop là dedans et pas trop branché
sera payé le prix de jean gabin viendra
peut-être
[Musique]
avec six heures lille en match
sortie le 7 juin
c'est là bordeaux
même pas
j'entends gorria miens je pleure
pour moi qui décollent vers une vaste
alerte pour nous autres les enfants
oui interview répondeur
c'est bien c'est thierry lhermitte je
tourne un film sérieux laissez moi un
message bip un film sérieux j'ai dû me
tromper de téléphone là je rappellerai
plus tard bonjour vous êtes bien chez
richard berry je mange un yaourt et
c'est un message bip
bah écoute richard je voulais juste en
profiter pour embrasser ta femme et mes
gosses charles
le pire dans la pub c'est pas de faire
la pub c'est les gens qui ont pas
bonjour vous êtes bien chez monsieur
madame timsit on est les parents désolé
laissez un message bip je suis avec
patrick un tout se passe bien et la
pression petits tricots il a les slips
marqué avec les jours de la semaine donc
il pourra pas se tromper il a sa
casquette il a le produit pour soleil
non je vous le passez deux secondes je
viens vendredi un vendredi je suis là
c'est normal si on n'a pas crevé bonjour
vous êtes bien chez laetitia casta si
vous n'êtes pas patrick timsit laissez
moi un message bip bombe à laetitia faut
arrêter de m'appeler maintenant aller
chez thierry ardisson je suis très épais
quelqu'un est tué à confectionner c'est
pas toi donc arrête de bousiller mon
répondeur de messages laetitia c'est
patrick timsit je ne laisserai pas de
message bonjour vous êtes bien chez
florent pagny 6,6 pour un conseil fiscal
laissez moi un message biblique
florent pagny bon ben maintenant voilà
ça y est j'ai acheté le disque des
problèmes fiscaux sont réglés maintenant
tu repars où c'est un autre problème tu
viens nous voir tu fais un peu plus
sinon tu peux pas tu peux vendre le site
qui est planqué
bonjour vous êtes bien chez les inédits
et zidane je veux un truc pour les
cheveux laissé un message bien on
n'hérite pas te parler si nous on est là
on n'a pas le droit de parler on peut
pas voir du enfin c'est pas possible
bonjour vous êtes chez genre d'armand je
sais j'ai muet pour les uns mais s'il
vous plaît
girard j'ai souffert pour toi j'ai
souffert je t'ai vu chez thierry
ardisson et voulait raconter une
histoire abidal à la place et la mode
raconter c'est pas une histoire habib
gérard quand c'est toi qui la raconte
je te jure elle est drôle vif et wen a
dit oui tu savais c'est pourquoi je suis
consterné parce que j'ai pas fait qu'ils
fissent between bitume non et même la
malle et vers l'intérieur c'est kif kif
between voilà voilà
[Musique]
m'enfin ça peut aider
non c'est un mec gérard excuse moi si je
la rate mais c'est un mec c'est
l'histoire habitent c'est vrai qu'on
prend débit des notes aux émetteurs nets
kiki qu'il veut apprendre l'anglais est
il conçu comme ça toutes les petites
annonces et ils vous apprenez l'anglais
en 6 même 3000 euros et regardant
neuf semaines 4000 euros il n'a pas les
moyens il ya vraiment apprendre
l'anglais il est comme un fou et tout
d'un coup ils voyaient d'annonce
apprenez l'anglais en 3 jours 10 euros
et il n'est pas possible à une coquille
s'est passé c'est c'est pas enfin c'est
pas la somme c'est pas en même temps il
est très embêté idées au chômage rue
mais gérard lafay encore mieux et je
sens la vue l'ouïe et donc il dit il
faut que j'aille voir quand même enfin
c'est peut-être une coquille mais c'est
peut-être 100 euros et pas de vison et
dans 100 euros je prends comme on l'a
fait il arrive là il sonne à la porte il
est là avec sa petite annonce il est où
navré il sait que c'est une coquille
il ya un hindou qui ouvrait qui ouvre
comme ça quand il fait beau oui excusez
moi sorges
j'ai lu apprenez l'anglais pour pour 10
euros en trois jours c'est peut-être une
bêtise mais est ce que c'est vrai et
c'est kif kif
it will
histoire de vie est ici que j'ai planté
trois fois de suite
elle est très bien racontée mais ça
reste quand même une histoire habillé
d'un costume n'inviter que je racontais
la faim qui après de repartir c'est pas
courageuse et kamikaze a fait la
différence entre quelqu'un qui va perdre
quelqu'un qui va gagner
moi j'ai perdu que non ah bah oui alors
qu'il a acquis la san roque et parmi nos
eaux là
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
bonsoir à vous de venir vers nous
cette mention
alors vous adore vous avez vous adore
parler de vous et les larmes dans les
yeux comme cela dit il faut qu'ils
viennent a dit on va pas le déranger ce
soir enfin c'est bien parce que sa
première grande télé s'il aurait clip et
s'il avait été programmée ouais alors
que là comment ça va pas ça c'est bien
une carte de bons clients tout de suite
déjà combien de mecs qui est venu déjà
déjà nos jours aussi
alors voilà un bon bloc michel serrault
voilà bah tu as tenu un prix déjà vous
souhaitez c'est maintenant poser des
questions a pas faire un one man show
revenant
jean vincent tu sais oui alors comment
ça s'est passé alors ce tournage mais
ton micro dans la bouche comment ça
s'est passé
elle était gentille avec toi si le
premier jour ça s'est passé comment
quand vous êtes arrivés tous les deux tu
la connaissez déjà tu l'avais rencontré
vanessa une fois ouais tu vas te marier
avec elle impressionne comme trac quand
tu la vois maintenant ça c'est un peu un
petit clip au début des guides puissent
tutu l'embrassant clé en tout cas tu as
dû point parce que c'est ton premier
tour de manège et qui roulait en ferrari
ce qu'a fait alors les deux oscars mais
ce n'est peut-être pas si les diables
christophe rhodia way un téléfilm qui
s'appelle la classe du brevet ouais de
l'embellie à gruissan produire c'est lui
qui a fait le buzz du shaba mortelle n'a
pas plus à new york
il faut mettre à l'aise quand même un
petit peu et ghislain mais c'est déjà si
on veut la vivre ce que tu veux changer
de l'été j'ai c'est de se protéger c'est
pas évident mais surtout la tienne
démission quoi ce serait là vous vous
protège bon sinon mais on voit bien
qu'on me force et l école des fans on a
tout verrouillé mais protégé il pourra
pas le chopper tu veux qu'on protège on
va le protéger le pays s'ils ne la
proche pas qu'ils les touchent pas ne va
pas me pourrir michel c'est voter j'ai
le temps pour les clubs échangistes
alors ça se passe comment
et eux
là il a pu 50 ans de purgatoire non
allez bye baby c'est pas personnel plus
non c'est pas la peine
c'est foutu pour toi tu vas crever shell
andreu bien je termine ces messieurs
donc bonjour vous avez grillage sodielec
jospin je vais revenir laissez moi un
message bip
on s'est pas ennuyé chantois sans toi on
s'est ennuyé sans toi non mais non mais
c'est vrai c'est pas un moulin faut pas
revenir partie revenir parvenir rester
si vous aimez et à progresser au tennis
pendant son temps de vacances parce que
moi je les ai vus jouer une fois et
magnétiques pas terrible bonjour vous
êtes bien chez dieudonné
si c'est pour la vérité si je mens 3
merci de laisser un message bip qu'est
ce que ça veut dire mais vous la voyez à
dieudonné d'un côté le côté le monde
non c'est quoi si ça tape à l'oeil
il a un spectacle qui s'appelait le
divorce de patrick que j'ai vu que les
palmarès puisque pas mal moi je me suis
non mais c'est rien de le dire
ouais c'est vraiment que sur scène c'est
super drôle quoi et c'est vrai que voilà
et puis y ait eu un débordement sur chez
fogiel et puis un débordement à sketches
drôles ou pas drôle c'est même pas un
débordement parce que là déjà je prends
en partie un voile à sketches drôles ou
pas drôle c'est pas important ça c'est
pas grave jusque là on a tous fait des
trucs drôles ou pas drôle et c'est après
c'est entre temps mais je trouve que ça
se complique c'est entre les sketches
donc je dirais ben je sais pas quoi elle
est entre les sketches fait pas de
sketches quoi mais quel message tu lui
laisses un fait pas de catch entre les
sketches toi espèce basket je suis paumé
mois quand c'est lui qui parle quand
c'est pas lui qui parle si c'est lui qui
parle quand il parle c'est vraiment
déplacé quand quand tout d'un coup c'est
un personnage ça va donc quand il parle
nazis qui met à un vrai uniforme de
nazis quand il continue par les nazis
entre les sketches sans avoir le costard
et et dans le monde et à la télé ça ça
me gêne vraiment parce que c'est plus
que ça me gêne
ça me ça me ça me ça m'horripile ça me
rend fou patrick toi dans tes sketches
moi je me souviens quand je te voyais
sur scène à l'époque qui avait des trucs
incroyables appareils sont les crevettes
parce qu'on a beaucoup parlé mais si on
met y avait un moment où tu disais mon
grand-père était acteur dans shoah il a
fini mannequin c'est bon ça manque quand
même avait absolument mais j'imagine que
si tu devais me disais ça oui sauf que
moi j'écoutais un truc il ya deux trucs
que je voudrais dire moi hein j'ai fait
un sketch qui s'appelle y sont partout
dans mais parce que creusot et ce
jusqu'à police et vachement province
étaient les catholiques les jupes et
âmes mais j'ai eu les les j'ai eu les
compliments yasser arafat
donc c'est à dire que c'est plus c'est
plus pareil que tout d'un coup c'est
vrai que je dis et dans un sketch où je
disais cette vie cette fois arabe manpo
disait le colon israélien qui va sur le
mur des lamentations et ce repenti il
dit après avoir tabassé un palestinien
pourquoi je n'ai pas tué pourquoi je
n'ai pas tué donc arafat a retenu ça et
puis le juif retient les catholiques et
puis le catholique retient les musulmans
on avait pour tout le monde si elle
avait pour détrousser des spectacles que
tu écrivais avec bruno gaccio et
jean-françois halin et jean-françois
signal non seulement est donc ce sont
vraiment des slogans succès alors
l'acteur d'anchois le mannequin chez mon
cerveau normalement serait dû faire un
scandale à l'époque ça passé assez
inaperçu enfin tout le monde trouvait ça
dans sa taxe ça sauter au plafond quand
même il ya un ensemble et puis c'est
pareil c'est sur scène quoi je passais
pas dans la rue au bistrot avec des
propos comme ça quoi c'est juste la
différence c'est c'est schumacher et
conduit à 360 km heure sur circuit
est-ce qu'il a le droit de conte de
conduire comme ça sur une autoroute
là je trouve que dieudonné conduit à 350
km heure sur autoroute voies sens
inverse
s'appelle de la mairie
mais
pendant les jeux
[Musique]
non loin du compte
[Applaudissements]
lausanne a mené trois fois ça
m'étonnerait trois fois penses tu allais
pas la maison l écrire à bâlois ne peut
pas dire ouais mais léo aller chez un
ami à elle n'était pas acquis et tu la
laisses aller chez cet ami mais elle
fait ce qu'elle veut il ya longtemps à
bon bah oui parce que tu sais si vous
êtes un couple moderne obame unis un
vieux couple moderne
bon qu'est ce qu'il ya questions d info
puis hier ses vues non c'est bon t'es
assez lu ses côtés de gucci à thomas
vraiment effet pluie avant et c'est un
peu comme ça
m
eh oui
à voir
non
[Applaudissements]
je reviendrai à
on arrive à dire des bêtises ah bon et
j'accueille maintenant vincent peillon
[Musique]
bonsoir l'instant payant vous connaissez
tous le monde oui laurent m'a dit 'si à
payant mois après il m'a dit je leurs
inconditionnels mais c'est le fait que
j'ai pas lu le livre
ouais mais malgré tout ami oui j'aime
bien les noms je trouve ça c'est malin
alors vincent peillon député ps de la
somme de 1997 à 2002 dirigeants depuis
1994 du ps co fondateur avec arnaud
montebourg du mps le nouveau parti
socialiste vous ai présidé la mission
parlementaire française sur le
blanchiment
ce qui nous vaut un livre qui s'appelle
les milliards noir du blanchiment chez
hachette littératures voilà mais
auparavant voudrais vous féliciter de
votre récente élection comme député
européen et vous demandez de commenter
quelques déclarations vous avez pu faire
suite aux résultats de cette élection
alors vous avez déclaré raffarin c'est
fort raffarin n'a pas une mission à
accomplir mais une démission a donné oui
le sentiment que j'ai eu c'était qu'on
était un peu encore dans la dans la
comédie après le résultat des élections
puisque d'un côté ça fait trois fois 1
qui a manifestement une sanction assez
forte et en même temps la réaction de
mes amis politiques étaient dire ça va
très mal la france a de plus en plus mal
il ya plus en plus de chômeurs mais
gardons le encore trois ans pour
préparer la faire non sur moi je
considère que si on pense que ces
difficultés sont réelles ce que je crois
il faut lui dire à ce moment là deux
parties j'aimerais y est restée duré
trois ans des frayeurs là et vous dites
il faut dissoudre l'assemblée nationale
le seul moyen d'avoir un gouvernement
qui a une certaine légitimité
ça serait de revoter voilà c'est ce que
j'ai dit voilà il a dit les sens de la
formule il a dit raffarin ne réforme pas
la france il là des formes mais il est
un auteur et vous avez un au turn on
vient
bien c'est bien et c'est bien écrit il
s'appelle peillon peillon il est député
de la somme il a le sens de la formule
ça c'est cool ça c'est pas moi c'est
hélas le vague il est tout petit laid
psg om enfin il ya quand même
hollande fabius strauss kahn au prix
langue delanoë qui finalement on ne sait
pas encore lequel va être candidat en
2007 donc et cette espèce de guerre
picrocholine qui est insupportable aussi
vous êtes bien d'accord alors les
solutions vincent on a dix versions n'y
a pas de solution parce que vincent à
l'intérieur de son courant au parti
socialiste qui s'appelle le nouveau
parti socialiste le nps qu'il a fondé
avec arnaud montebourg
il ya du grabuge aussi c'était quand
même un intérêt de votre sous courant il
ya du grabuge
il ya la première biographie de
montebourg qui va sortir le 18 août
écrite par guy benhamou chez stock et
montebourg vous soupçonne d'avoir
alimenté le biographe en lui balançant
des les horreurs sur lui ce qui non non
c'est pas ça je vais vous répondre
franchement c'est un sujet vous savez
pas ce qu'on va peut-être en parler avec
montebourg on a formé un couple où elle
a appelé starsky et hutch faisait
beaucoup de gens on nous a appelés
pompon est modeste
on nous a appelés et c est ça un peu
intrigué que deux un peu plus jeunes qui
prennent les riches des porte parole du
parti socialiste dans son histoire va
donner sa démission on a fait ce congrès
dont vous parlez voilà donc on est très
observé et certains ont eu le sentiment
qu'il y avait entre nous et on vous le
jouez un petit peu avec ça des dix
sentiments mais ce n'est pas la réalité
de ce que je crois mais on verra quand
elle sortira cette biographie on la sait
que l'attendent et grandes choses pour
guy benhamou en tout cas
c'est que je crois que arnaud montebourg
quand il en a eu connaissance a pas
toujours reconnu un certain nombre
d'éléments qui faisait partie de ses
combats politiques
voilà mais je crois que cette affaire
est derrière nous la nous avait l'air un
peu réconcilié puisque vous le remerciez
dans l'ouverture du livre qui vous amène
ce soir s'appelle donc les milliards
noir du blanchiment chez hachette
littératures alors le blanchiment basse
et c'est quoi ces laver l'argent sale
quoi c'est l'argent de la drogue la
prostitution de la corruption de la
contrefaçon du trafic d'armes trafic de
personnes trafic d'organes maintenant
qui se développe beaucoup en europe
ça produit de l'argent beaucoup d'argent
on dit que la somme totale du crime est
au delà du produit intérieur brut de la
france a versé plus de 200 milliards
d'euros
et ça ne cesse de croître malgré toutes
les dénonciations internationales mais
quand vous avez cet argent venue la
prostitution du trafic de personnes vous
pouvez pas le dépenser tout de suite
donc il faut arriver à le remettre dans
des circuits pour le blanchir ça venait
des blanchisseuses d'al capone un passé
par bonds et donc il faut rendre cet
argent qui vient du crime
il faut lui donner l'apparence de
l'argent au net et donc il ya tout un
processus à travers les banques à
travers des sociétés écrans pour rendre
cet argent est ce qui fait qu'après vous
trouvez les grandes sociétés qui sont
des sociétés du mobilier des banques qui
sont tenus en fait par des capitaux
mafieux mais on le sait maintenant ce
que cet argent était blanc ce qui fait
que dans le fond vous avez un pouvoir du
crime même sur l'économie en apparence
ne râle pas seulement le souteneur
traditionnel nom des grandes boîtes qui
ont pignon sur rue et derrière les
capitaux sont des mecs avec des critères
mais attaché-case des bureaux celui
qu'on a arrêté je raconte ça dans le
bouquins la grande histoire du
blanchiment en europe le type qui
étaient chargés de gérer tous les
comptes pour blanchir l'argent de la
drogue du cartel de calais sortez
d'harvard et a plutôt intérêt jurado
mais voilà quand vous voulez utiliser
les mécanismes financiers qui sont
compliqués c'est pas le petit malfrat
habituel c'est effectivement le marin a
sortis des grandes écoles et qui
travaillent à la city de londres
alors vous parlez des paradis fiscaux
vous dit que oui évidemment quand on
pense à paradis fiscal
on s'imagine que ce à quoi un super
sympa avec delago une mer bleue l'egypte
des petites banques comme serveuse c'est
très sympathique vous dites que
malheureusement c'est pas ça aurait eu
quelques avancées il ya eu monaco quand
même que quand même des avancées et puis
à l'époque de dominique strauss kahn en
99 il ya eu saint martin et saint
barthélémy où là bas personne paye
d'impôts enfin c'est vraiment là la fin
d'emploi du territoire français est donc
là bas dominique strauss kahn en 1999
avait tenté de mettre les choses un peu
d'aplomb et depuis qu raffarin est venue
la redonner l'indépendance fiscale à ces
deux îles ce qui fait qu'on repart en
arrière c'est ce que lebouc avait un peu
de ça pour moi et président de cette
mission réunit qui a duré trois ans a
été la plus et la mission parlementaire
de la vème république
on a pu très modestement parce que ses
sujets avant spa mais on a pu faire
bouger quelques lignes vous avez parlé
monaco on est allé au liechtenstein
luxembourg ça fait des grands scandales
des incidents diplomatiques mais au bout
du bout ça bougeait un peu
alors on à l'indépendance fiscale de
saint-barthélemy mais tous les sujets
qui préoccupent les gens qui nous
écoutent la marée noire le prestige mais
à l'europe et 2000 chômeurs de et on
voit raffarin qui dit patrons voyous
mais le patron voyou et dans un petit
canton de suisse ont détalé de tout et
rien ne change les grandes faillites que
l'on voit enron ou récemment remanié par
mme c'est l'utilisation massive chaque
fois des mêmes procédés société cran
fiduciaire ça passe toujours par la
suisse comme la corruption politique
toutes les histoires qu'on suit et
celles qui sont en train de ressortir
avec les frags frégates de taïwan vous
retrouver les mêmes acteurs
c'est quand même quelque chose alors je
lui dirai en face que dire c'est que les
coupables sont identifiés et qui a pas
de volonté politique réelle pour les
poursuivre si vous me reprochez
haussière afin par exemple le projet d'
amnistie fiscale sur les capitaux
tricolore évaporé à l'étranger vous
et là si l'état accepte que ses capitaux
reviennent en france
l'état devient defacto lui-même un
blanchissage vous allez institué
monsieur sarkozy en grand blanchisseurs
national et tous les mafieux ça a été le
cas en italie d'ailleurs inscrit à faire
revenir les gars leur argent pendant
vous continuer de demander quand même à
ceux qui gagnent 1500 euros par mois par
exemple célibataire de payer leurs
impôts
on est dans une aberration politique
donc je pense j'espère que ça ne se fera
pas alors là ce serait vraiment rare
rupture de tout sens commun votre livre
est très complet on voit que ce problème
des capitaux mobile l'issue du crime
finalement ça favorise les crises
financières parce que c'était ils ont
des comportements un petit peu erratique
vous parlez de la mondialisation
criminels face à laquelle la communauté
internationale était impuissante vous
dit qu'il faudrait qu'on baptise dans
les années qui viennent un ordre public
mondial vous dit en fait que le
capitalisme est malade et que tout ça
est intrinsèque au capitalisme et c'est
pour ça qu'on a un peu inquiet sur la
façon de se sortir de cette situation
parce que s'il faut abolir le
capitalisme pour abolir le blanchiment
c'est pas demain la veille et quand même
hein qu'est ce qu'il faut faire on a
fait un grand désordre quand désordre
mondial
c'est la même chose qui existait dans
nos pays au début du 19e siècle ont
enlevé la révolution industrielle
c'est pas droit social les gones wright
16 heures vous avez même pas le suffrage
universel et on va construire dans le
cadre de l'état nation pour essayer
quand même de faire que ce soit pas
simplement les intérêts financiers qui
domine
or ces des combats ces 10 830 10 848 on
va construire progressivement par le
combat ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui d'un
mot vilain mais les régulations pour
essayer de nous donner face aux intérêts
de l'argent des droits et des moyens
d'intervenir
bon c'est ce qu'il faut reconstruire
aujourd'hui faut pas que nostalgique de
la nation ne pas y revenir
il faut construire avec l'europe et dans
le cadre multilatéral ce qui n'existe
pas aujourd'hui un ordre public mondial
lorsqu'on est dans un désordre public
mondial qui fait d'ailleurs très vous
verra nos concitoyens l'attendait pas à
ma question aussi puissante
si pour supprimer le blanchiment il faut
détruire le capitalisme c'est pas demain
la veille
je n'ai pas dit alors si je vous réponds
je ne pense pas du tout qu'il faille
détruire le capitalisme je pense qu'il
faut lui donner des règles
aujourd'hui la première question c'est
lui donner des règles parce qu'il n'en a
pas vous êtes utopiste sans doute un
petit peu on va faire une interview de
pierre
[Musique]
est ce que vous croyez encore que
l'argent peut ne pas contrôler le monde
oui je pense que c'est un combat qu'il
faut mener qui a pas on est partagé est
ce que vous croyez encore que le
libéralisme n'est pas la seule option
possible
le libéralisme politique de la
révolution française c'était d'ailleurs
la liberté individuelle c'est mon option
l'ultralibéralisme de berlusconi non et
je pense que on s'endette ondra bientôt
ça à 20 ans dans le fond pas plus fin
vous croyez encore au socialisme oui je
crois au socialisme vous croyez encore à
françois hollande
bien sûr vous croyez encore qu'un jour
le ps aura un programme original et
novateur mais on va s'y mettre bientôt
pour vous y mettre là quand même
mais vous croyez encore que si tous les
gars du monde voulait se donner la main
je pense vous m'avez parlé tout à
l'heure des politiques parce que c'est
votre style je le comprends moi ce qui
m'a le plus choqué je vais vous le dire
c'est que dans ce combat les citoyens
s'en foutent totalement qu' il ya un
petit arabe au coin de la rue où la
prostituée roumaine elle gêne mafieux
derrière ne gêne pas tout ce qui se
cache derrière et qui absolument
colossal personne n'en parlait quand on
a mené ce combat
moi j'ai vu en aide à nos politiques
autant que vous voulez mais bonnet d'âne
aussi aux citoyens ni donc on se donne
la main sert tout le monde se bouge
est ce qu'on voyait encore en la france
black blanc beur bien entendu et puis
c'est pas encore dans l'intégration ne
pensais pas qu'on est passé du côté
maintenant du communautarisme
définitivement non je pense que c'est
une grande bagarre
on a au quotidien mais je pense pas que
ce soit le fond il ya beaucoup de gens
qui sont mobilisés depuis un ou deux ans
on a des dérapages absolument
inadmissible et je pense que on y
arrivera croyant encore autour de lionel
jospin
je crois j'observe ouais vous voyez
encore la paix en palestine
je pense que c'est un des sujets sur
lesquels vous parliez d'utopie tous
devaient regarder des dagues qui parlait
de paix perpétuelle ou qui parlait d'
union européenne
et on se moquer d'eux il ya deux siècles
je pense que pour les années qui
viennent c'est le grand sujet encore et
encore la france
oui je pense qu'on a une crise de
l'esprit public qui est profonde et moi
je suis très attaché à la france pas une
france fermée sur elle même mais cette
france qui essayait de porter les
valeurs universelles
je pense qu'ils ont été sincère dans nos
convictions crois que c'est un pays qui
pourrait faire plus pour lui-même plus
pour les siens et plus pour les autres
aussi
or le blanchiment et
sur moi
[Applaudissements]
vous parler un petit peu dans le type du
financement des partis alors michel
mouillot était là la semaine dernière il
est reparti avec une manette est reparti
avec une manette que le relais gentiment
donné nous expliquer que depuis 1990
finalement rien n'avait changé
finalement aujourd'hui les partis
politiques touché 150 millions d'euros
par an qui se partageaient allègrement
mais qu' il continuait quand même à
attirer du pognon aux entreprises en
prendre un peu partout d'une certaine
façon excuces était d'expliquer quand on
est en bas on peut pas financer sa
propre campagne politique dans la loi
dont on a parlé j'ai fait plusieurs
campagnes électorales
c'est les impôts collectif qui paye les
campagnes politiques même des
conseillers généraux je vous donne un
exemple pour que les gens comprennent
vous avez le droit à 50000 euros près de
60000 pour une campagne législative et
on vous en retour sera l'état le préfet
de votre région 25000 dont on calcule
tous notre campagne à 25000 euros pour
pas avoir à taper la grand-mère ou taper
comme vous le dites l'entreprise du
point et ça fait des années que ça dure
donc moi j'ai fait des campagnes
électorales payées sur fonds publics où
il ya une vraie moralisation parce que
vous n'avez rien à demander et donc ce
qu'il a dit la semaine dernière est
totalement faux comment il se trouve il
est pas mal non un nom bien bien à moins
bien
non moi j'ai eu un petit un petit pépin
au début et puis après ça a été très
bien dans vos débuts non le type est
passé tel qu'il est on entré pour nommer
à dire que non au début c'est bon le
combat contre les mafieux honnêtement ne
s'était pas c'était pas grave pour moi
c'est bizarre ça vous gêne pas non mais
ça me gêne pas moi ce qui me gêne c'est
le tout d'un coup c'est quand on tape
dans les caisses du citoyen ça ça me
gêne moelleux le combat contre le
mafieux c'est un combat de deux flics de
police enfin je veux dire ne sais pas
voyez et tout d'un coup
donc le côté mathieu le côté voyou le
côté blanchiment tout ça je me dis mais
après tout ce sont des voyous quoi être
sanaa depuis l'alcool interdit tout ça
c'est pas grave ce sont les bâillonnant
ski ce qui est gênant c'est que tout
d'un coup il ya des gens pour qui on
vote et kiki à 11,7 confiance et cela
pour les combattre quoi plus que les
mafieux quoi et mathieu c'est un combat
normal quoi
ceci étant dit honnêtement vous
aujourd'hui en europe se développe on
vient de voter pour les européennes le
trafic d'organes
zerka des types qui vendent aux lorrains
ou leur corps n'est pour 15 100 euros
pour qu'on les ventes dans nos cliniques
à 100000 euros et ya des types qui font
donc voyez entre 15 cent et cent mille
de l'argent avec ça vous dit je m'en
fous c'est normal roger nord c'est
normal le combat sur la police et la
justice
exister dans notre pays aujourd'hui le
fait que la coopération judiciaire et
policière marche pas en europe c'est
quand même votre affaire m'enfin bon
élevé dans les caisses
au niveau municipal ça ça me gêne c'est
un vrai débat vous dire effectivement
qu'on est contre le trafic d'organes
je trouve ça tellement normal enfin je
dis un peu serré et de résignation
devant ses activités de blanchiment
parce que beaucoup de gens comme dit
patrick pense que c'est la sphère de la
police et que c'est pas leurs affaires
alors qu'un mec qui valent dans la
caisse d'une mairie on pense que c'est
plus notre affaire ça vous ça vous fait
quoi dans la discussion si j'ai pas tout
imprimer la politique la fin il ya
beaucoup de choses hein j'ai du mal à
suivre tout ce que vous dites à beaucoup
d'affaires pour la plupart d'ailleurs
que j'ai absolument pas suivi et puis je
crois qu'on se revoir
[Musique]
c'est dire la trame sonore
le seul qui trouve grâce à ses yeux à
part johnny depp tient dans le creux de
la vague en ce moment un peu grossi
enfin c'est nécessairement assez
irresponsable de parler comme ça j'ai
jamais voter et je n'arrive pas je
n'arrive pas à vous écouter ce costume
qui va se passer quoi regarder ça vous
parle beaucoup et boma et s'est jetée
croche que j'y arrive pas je sais pas
pourquoi une fréquence qu'un grand chez
même si vous dites des choses
intéressantes on sent un ronronnement
très très bien étudié travaillé non on
décroche on est d'accord avec lui sa
peur c'était pour expliquer le fait que
le décroche je ne savais pas de vous et
de ce que vous venez de dire qui étaient
ces charges et il y avait beaucoup de
choses quoi mais c'était clair c'est en
règle générale c'est toujours on va
faire bien on va faire mieux on va aider
les envahi des maisons est toujours que
des histoires de fric et toujours que
l'histoire de guerre toujours si ces
termes éthiques à satee imperméable à 7
j'ai pas le temps voilà j'ai pas le
temps
ben je sais pas mais c'est vrai que
c'est des discours qui sont quand même
assez encourageant la volonté d'agir et
c'est ça nous saoule de belles paroles
on est ivre comme ça on est grisé par ce
parce rythmée par cette volonté je pense
sincère de bien faire politiquement mais
moi j'ai peur de main de me réveiller
avec la gueule de bois quoi il fait
donner une carte de lens en branle c'est
la dernière
un centime
[Musique]
j'ai voulu si allez vous conserver sa
petite amie
holy vincent maintenant way you lie sony
aura bientôt alors bonjour venez tous
les deux pour la sortie du film de serge
frydman ou en anges
[Applaudissements]
connaissant tous les rôles de méchant on
s'était dit qu'on a dit ça il ya des
samples de batterie de portable
[Musique]
c'était pas brillant et maintenant
oh
soit
la scission ni leur chalet jean paul
gaultier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
henri marchal jean paul ii bonsoir 2100
j'en passe alors tony vous êtes une
enfant de la balle
puisque vous êtes la fille de bill
marchal acteur réalisateur américain le
mari de mme michèle morgan à une époque
est donc le grand père de la fameuse
sarah marshall et oui vous êtes parent
d'un petit peu que ça marche c'est ma
nièce c'est votre voix là mais je la
connais très peu mais on s'est vus
il ya assez longtemps avant qu'elle
épouse j'ai oublié son nom avec son
alexandre anthony voilà il faudra
beaucoup tous les deux mais y paraît
dans vos yeux avec la fille donc de
belmarsh a et de micheline presle
accèdent évidemment cette grande actrice
consentirait qu'on adore tous mes fils
prenne voilà et quand vous étiez enfant
vous dormiez dans une chambre qui
jouxtait la salle de projection du
studio des ursulines
alors quand il était tout petit il
entendait le son et puis ensuite j'ai
devenues copines avec l'ouvreuse et puis
elle vous laisser rentrer dans la salle
du studio des ursulines
comme ça vous avez vu très jeunes des
films de godard de bergman les einstein
enfin vraiment vous avez une formation
très précoce j'avais la cabine du
projectionniste était à peu près on
était séparés par une cour de trois
mètres et donc l'été particulièrement il
aller fumer une clope sur le l'escalier
en métal et donc il ouvrait la porte de
la cabine et j'ai donc ce que j'ai pu
j'ai connu les films en entier par le
son je connais alexandre nevsky
pratiquement phonétiquement etc voilà
alors vous avez fait plein de films vous
à votre tour ensuite le plus connu
disons c'est vénus beauté institut qui a
été nominé sept fois aux césar qui avait
décroché quatre césar du meilleur film
du meilleur scénario de la meilleure
réalisatrice et meilleur espoir féminin
pour la fameuse audrey tautou qui depuis
a fait jusqu'à la fluoration que tu
voudrais tautou non peut-être que tu la
connais mieux sous le nom de
amélie à kaffrine qu'il y avait du
punjab heures et votre dernier film
j'étais france boutiques dont judith
godrèche c'est venu parler ici cette
idée alors jean paul gaultier vous en
plus des activités qui porte votre nom
va pas toutes les énumérer parce que ça
commence à faire pas mal
vous avez signé en mars dernier votre
première collection pour hermès ou
revisiter les grands classiques de la
maison dans un esprit
voilà moderniser gauthier ludique vous
continuez à travailler pour le cinéma et
le spectacle vous êtes occupé de peter
greenaway de caro et jeunet de besson
d'almodovar de madonna d'yvette horner
de johnny hallyday et de sylvie vartan
alors j'ai lu dans une interview j'ai lu
dans une interview récemment tejada
sylvie vartan les autres j'étais content
mais l'appel d'offres est contente dans
son bouquin que ça donc on a lu le
bouquin de sylvie vartan et à aucun
moment elle se plaint de vous alors la
seule chose qui aurait pu arriver c'est
qu'elle oublie de parler de vous mais
elle dit pas de mal de vous dans son
bouquin alors je ne sais pas je me
demande je me demande si en fin de
compte j'ai pas lu un autre livre arrêts
ouais parce que je sais pas il y en a
pas deux sur sylvie vartan à celui là il
est écrit par elle dans celui qui est
écrit par elle ne parle pas de boue du
tout alors ça doit être l'hôte écrit par
un journaliste que j'ai lu et je croyais
que c'était celui 1 où il ya une ville
et une couverture pas très généreux
vertueux voilà c'est pas elle on a
vraiment cherché elle dit rien contre
vous à l'eau mais simplement de bars et
de douces et ouais ouais quand même à
l'argent
alors justement si vous deviez relooké
vincent peillon quand même un homme
politique qu'est bulku plutôt beau gosse
je veux dire les choses un kéké gens
travailleurs tout mais au niveau du look
est ce que vous pensez qu'il doit rester
comme ça pour pour faire sérieux pour
faire hommes politiques la cravate et
costume ça pour être très honnête ça me
fascine pas tellement le fait d'
habiller comment les politiciens parce
que je trouve que bon ils ont certaines
règles à appliquer tout bon ben voilà
délai à quoi les équipes classées le
mieux non pour eux habillés en animateur
télé ça vous tenterait jean-paul moi par
exemple la rentrée qu'est ce que vous me
conseilleriez parce que ça me va très
bien
18 ans je suis habillée comme ça va bien
comme ça un peu trop c'est comme une
espèce d'image de marque et on regarde
moi j'ai pris ma réussite
jean paul gaultier est ce que vous
faites des fautes de goût aux sûrement
plein on s'est déjà retrouvé en train de
faire des courses au dimanche matin avec
un survêt et des mocassins si vous êtes
arrivé ça ce genre de qui peut devenir
bien ce site mais qui peut devenir bien
ça dépend comme tout est fait de la
façon dont s'est fait quoi il est des
choses qui sont à une époque horrible
tout ce qu'il faut pas faire puis après
qu'il ait au contraire qu'on trouve on
passe super un stade différent et on
trouve ça plutôt rigolo et bien vous
êtes déjà retrouvé au marcel devant un
match de foot par exemple
ben non je regarde pas
wedge le foot alors déjà à l'église en
mini jupe est arrivé 2014 est jamais
allé je porte pas une jupe l'équipage le
porte de temps à autre mais elle est
rarement demain jusqu'à demain après
midi sur france 5
absolument absolument je ne sais pas un
match de foot non non à 15h30 sur france
5 il ya un documentaire de tonie
marshall sur jean paul gaultier voilà
alors au début quand on vous a dit de
faire un documentaire vous vous êtes dit
oui l'a jamais fait le documentaire
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
et puis
vous pareil vous dites oh là là je vais
pas voir une équipe sur le dos pendant
cinq mois donc au départ c'était pas
c'était pas évident savait pas encore
que celle est tonie marshall
quand j'ai su que c'était elle et ce qui
nous réunit c'est un film un film sur la
mode un film des années 50 un film de
jacques becker qui s'appelle falbala
dont l'héroïne est votre maman micheline
presle et il se trouve que micheline
presle vous vous l'adorez dervout
l'avait habillée pour le propos les
césar on voit ça à la fin du
documentaire d'ailleurs tout à fait
puisque bon moi je suis un enfant de la
télé on va dire donc j'ai regardé la
télé tuant tout gamin et je me souviens
qu'il ya un moment j'avais vu l'émission
des folies bergères sur les folies
bergères je voulais à billets je voulais
faire des costumes pour les folies
berchère ça a commencé comme ça et puis
après j'ai vu falbala et là ça a été le
coup de foudre totale je vous dis non
c'est la mode
moi ça je vous devais avoir je n'ai pas
12 ans 10 12 ans et c'est quand même
probablement le seul film qui raconte le
processus d'une collection de haute
couture du début jusqu'à la fin se dire
qu'après ça c'était la vérité c'était ma
bible en quelques secondes voilà un
certain jacques becker très beau film
alors le documentaire s'appelle les
falbalas de jean paul gaultier est pas
pour rien donc vous parler de votre vie
professionnelle et puis de votre vie
privée alors ce plan professionnel
on apprend que vous dessinez deux
collections par an dont vous êtes
toujours dans l'urgence quoi c'est ouais
ouais c'est un petit peu c'est ça le
rythme de la mode c'est c'est assez
étonnant
en plus on peut faire quelquefois des
collections qui sont plusieurs saisons
en même temps enfin la cheville à la
fois sur l'été et l'hiver enfin alors
découvre aussi dans ce documentaire que
vous laisser appeler monsieur comme coco
chanel c'est appeler mademoiselle
jusqu'à présent que disait jean-paul ou
d'abord parce qu'on n'était pas nombreux
et puis j'ai commencé par du affaires du
prêt-à-porter
ce n'était pas la même façon là même le
même vocabulaire on va dire que dans la
couture où j'ai commencé et en insistant
mais l'accord comme j'ai pris certaines
personnes certains comment met-on la
première d'atelier qui venait de la
couture elle avait l'habitude de dire
monsieur pascal travailler avec monsieur
givenchy donc ça a été monsieur donc je
me suis retrouvée d'un seul coup paf
avec monsieur ouais ça va un peu chanel
qua non sauf que c'était ma demoiselle
dont elle m'a pas dit mademoiselle sera
peut-être un peu plus étonné c'est le
mademoiselle avons parlé de votre vie
privée aussi d'une façon assez franche
de trous 1
ouais je prends aussi sinon c'est vrai
c'est assez ouais ouais
gk ce documentaire vous avez évité une
psychanalyse sûrement mais oui c'est ça
ce que je disais en fin de compte j'ai
merci thani c'est tout à fait ça bien
alors tous les deux vous avez regardé la
caméra où il ya le rouge
et vous allez dire en même temps si vous
le dit pas en même temps ça marchera pas
si m synchro attention pas être synchro
je vous donnais un tel magot vite
magnéto serge rien à 3 attention 2 3
magnéto serge c'est quoi cette histoire
pour tous les invités attention non mais
même c'était bien de 3 2 3 magnéto serge
mais aucun déchet pas qu'ils estiment le
couple me suis toujours pareil moment
même un peu ma poitrine c'est toujours
arriver une espèce de gouttes comme ça
qui remonte c'est toujours pareil alors
que vous vous souvenez ici se doit être
arrondis et où je ne sais pas qu'est-ce
qui prend ce patronage là mais à chaque
fois c'est la même forme
j'ai pas la forme du sein parce que
j'avais dit que je voulais avec plus de
bombay j'ai déjà fait la ratification
moi même j'ai encore une fois mon
arrondis comme ça en route qui remonte
on profite toujours pareil c'est comme
l'autre fois
et regardez là j'ai une espèce de
d'angle donc qui correspond à quoi cet
angle là je peux jamais un affront aussi
en q2 vous voyez ce que je veux dire
c'est que je sais pas s'il a respecté du
tout dessin derian bon tout et il faut
repenser nos manches et on la mange
admettons voilà sens à la sphère qu'elle
n'existe pas et après il faut surtout ce
morceau là ce morceau là qui doit être
d'un morceau d'un seul morceau et voilà
où ils arrivent pour me faire mon profil
regarder et il doit tenir comme ça voilà
france venant à 15h30 les falbalas de
jean paul gaultier
un documentaire de tonie marshall voilà
quel boulot quand ma famille alors
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous l'avez
eue là pendant cinq mois c'est
absolument étonnant c'est à dire que
je crois qu'il par dylan espèce de on va
dire qu un espèce de petit cimetière de
bouts de tissus des plumes jaillissantes
yagg d'état trucs comme ça
elle arriva derrière il tripote des tas
de morceaux comme ça il tripote
énormément il a absolument besoin de ça
il n'a pas de dessin il a vaguement des
trucs collé au mur qui regarde pas
souvent
et puis tripote il tripote il tripote de
ce qui a déplu à barton m et puis après
il commence à avoir une toile
et puis voilà c'est il ya des choses on
voit on le voit dans le documentaire il
ya des moments où ça rate complètement
où il sépare etc et puis tout d'un coup
ça vient et là c'est vraiment
intéressant parce que on voit qu est ce
que c'est qu'un moment où tout est là
parce que jean-paul il ne crée le
vêtement que par la parole il n'arrête
pas de parler
on aurait dit tout le temps alors là le
titre on t'a fait si ça fait ça puis au
bout d'un moment ils arrêtent de dire le
tissu il commence à dire alors là je
vais avoir ça un peu plus serré dit dont
l'âge de cloques et puis alors là je god
donc je vais remonter alors il faut il
faut je ne suis pas doubler et il se met
absolument la place du vêtement et à
partir de là le discours structure alors
qu'avant je viens de vêtements il
devient le vêtement est frappant et ça
est un peu après il perfectionne les
cinglés quoi moyens cintrée alors il ya
un autre événement concernant jean paul
gaultier c'est l'exposition pain couture
by jean paul gaultier à la fondation
cartier pour l'art contemporain
alors là il a transformé mille mètres
carrés en boulangerie et vous faites des
rebonds pas vous allez regarder votre
caméra on va recommencer l'expérience à
3 faisait dire my social avec vincent
plat allez vincent
attention un deux trois magnéto serge
[Musique]
houdan
tha
ça
[Musique]
l'agression
éthier non mais c'est dans la fondation
cartier pour l'art contemporain s'est
inventé la jupe aux roms et dernièrement
le maquillage pour hommes testés par
vincent perez josé garcia david beckham
non il ya des choses c'est à la fois
comment la frette tonifiant enfin décidé
une tonique et puis aussi les choses par
exemple pour les lèvres pour se protéger
mais en même temps que coloré un peu si
on veut mais ça peut être aussi très
neutre à la base et aussi pour je sais
pas les sourcils ou comme comme le col
des toits en toits ray c'est un tour des
yeux bon donc c'est des choses quand
même
on peut très bien les maîtres sans avoir
l'air maquillé gamme pour hommes
politiques mais je crois qu'il est
neutre et alors on se passe avec un
blaireau sait à quels sont les gestes
par exemple même pour le comme un stylo
voilà un stylo parce que c'est un geste
que un geste voilà quel peut être
l'avenir de la mode
on va faire une interview à la mode
est ce que vous pensez qu'un jour
pourrait être à la mode
les espadrilles montante ah oui tout à
fait les pantalons dans les chaussettes
totalement c'est pas beau quand même les
portails wilson tout va à lambert wilson
l'hameçon non mais sérieux y mettrait le
pantin et chaussées ce très beau gosse
les soutiens gorge pour homme d'alluré
non mais c'est à laval ouais c'est vrai
c'est que tout va alors merlus
l'injustice c'est comme ça que les gens
fassent des gants le soutien gorge il
peut avoir des dd défendent si les
déciles la morphologie masculine
peut-être musclé mais oui à la partie du
moment il ya encore c'est pas comme une
prothèse quoi pour pour l afrique
kangourou le défendrai bien peut-être
c'est déjà la mode y en a certains qui
laisse le temps peu de beats bottes dans
une peau de 8
je veux dire pour avoir la [ __ ] plaisir
lors c'est comme les manteaux dont on
n'a pas de joueurs quoi si c'est une
pièce c'est joli quand même un jeu me
semble possible pourquoi pas un nom il
ya plein de choses qui sont faites comme
ça il ya les cadets il ya des dépôts de
poissons et tous qui sont incroyables
pour que les plans il ya plein de choses
qui sont faites donc la peau de bits
peut en effet être un élément pourquoi
pas peut-être qu'on fera pas d merci
c'est pourquoi qu'est ce qu'il en reste
et a sans cesse car de mes coéquipiers
il ya aussi un album édité par
la fondation cartier survol couture by
jean paul gaultier
hulot
bien alors tuvalu de coûts chez toi
maintenant la secousse y est
qu'est ce qui m'arrive
à
[Applaudissements]
amen
si jal
ouais silva tél
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au total voilà alors il a déjà une carte
une carte de quoi perdre deux beaux
gosses
ah oui car du beau gosse voilà très bien
ça comment ça va bien
donc après ma femme est une actrice dont
nous avons dit ici le plus grand bien
vous sortez ils vont atteindre le 25
août votre deuxième film ils se
marièrent et eurent beaucoup d'enfants
avec charlotte gainsbourg
emmanuelle seigner alain chabat à un
cohen le petit garçon du vieil homme et
l'enfant qui revient johnny depp qui
revient aussi parce qu'il était dans le
creux de la main c'est ce qu'on disait
un essai à tout à l'heure il a pris du
bide eu la grosse île et ils devraient
surveiller le johnny depp
anouk aimée claude berri et vous voilà
alors le pitch il ya un pitch normal
qu'ils seraient c'est une comédie sur la
difficulté de rester en couple
et puis à mon petit chat moi c'est le
mariage c'est l'enfer
le célibat c'est l'enfer l'adultère sait
tout faire et c'est vraiment ça plombe
bientôt de faire et quand tu vois le
film tu sors de là c'est paniquer non
non tu dises que c'est une comédie
derrière tout édifice en mai ce sinistre
l'idée l'idée c'était de le traiter
légèrement mais c'est vrai que ça
raconte ça s'est quand même dit au daily
jeu c'est pas gai du tout l'histoire
alors vous le traitez très bien être
d'une façon très sympathique mais quand
même tout et l'enfer quand tu veux si tu
seigneur khachaba et les marier avec
emmanuelle seigner qui le martyrisent
yara qu elle lui alors lui c'est le
célibataire que tard mais toute façon ça
se termine très mal pour lui il est
planté à la fin et puis à vous
alors il ya assez extraordinaire c'est
extraordinaire et ça ça m'a beaucoup
touché dans le film circule donc notre
ami yvan trompe sur le but est pour et
alors ils ont un truc avec charlotte
gainsbourg c'est qu'ils aiment bien
s'asperge etc de l'eau et un moment vous
asperger la maîtresse est la maîtresse
n'apprécie pas et là on voit en comprend
c'est vachement de subtiles on comprend
qu'à ce moment là vous vous dites je
préfère ma femme ça c'est très fort
c'est vrai qu'on ne le prend pas bien
mais avec ça
simon le bon bah bien ça fait ajouté
[Applaudissements]
ces bons sauts les cadets 1
bien d'y aller
avant
[Applaudissements]
on fait les côtés de laurent gbagbo
c'est bien
mais c'est moi ou c'est moi je calme à
jouer au large du port
ok
à
au genre toujours aux gens
bazot
voilà voilà
dont un dans le tour maintenant tu
portes
canal
donc tout le monde bien compris c'est la
dernière je crois que c'est la dernière
et vous si chez vous
je suis au niveau atteint tk c'est bien
à pranger à cette semaine chez moi comme
ça on est exactement dans le film d'yves
ans est le la maison qui ajuste il est
tous avec toi
non non non minoia on regarde ton mineur
charles mathon
un cours d'eau
et donc malheureusement avec la
maîtresse ça ne marche pas et là d'un
seul coup on sent bien il vend chan
[Musique]
est ce que vous allez faire j'ai regardé
la caméra où il ya le rouge
et vous allez dire magnéto serge et
pendant ce temps on va se sécher avec
micromania est le plus heureux des
hommes toi ah ouais ah ouais tu fais
quoi soit je rentre à la maison et toi
tu fais pas quant à la maison ben moi
aussi je rentre à la maison
ce moment il ya personne qui n'a pas
hésité à me faire pleurer toi et à la
santé publique et la belle vie tu vas
t'acheter ta bagnole on n'a que ça à
[ __ ] act up ou non du piolet [ __ ] et
arrête la boxe sur la crois que c'est
moi qui te tape dessus
elle a tous les mêmes problèmes on
cherche le stade pré me dl non elle va
me tuer civile une mercedes un chat a du
bon elle est géniale ta femme
ouais elle est géniale
[Musique]
je veux sortir mais aussi et prend du
temps pour ma part mais je sais pas tu
aurais pu me prévenir plus tôt j'aurais
même sa famille même son fils willem sa
maîtresse je suis pas sa maîtresse péter
quoi alors
bon mais terre c'est pas une histoire de
cul [ __ ] vous êtes comme masseuse
c'est exactement ça que je sais tout
pourquoi je sais tout je sais tout
et c'est un
elle sait quoi rien en fait elle sait
rien on attend on joue contre le bien ne
vous inquiétez pas on en est tous là
tout s'est croisé par exemple un
restaurant sa copine à dire parlant
d'elle qu'elle se doutait de quelque
chose doute
va diviser le monde en deux à travers
d'un côté ma femme de l'autre toutes les
autres j'ai choisi ma femme tu vas pas
bouger ton cul c'est normal c'est les
femmes qui débarrasse et se pisser
mais regarde toi c'est toi qui souffrent
tu viens avec tes histoires de princes
et de princesses contrat qu'on ne put
est tout petit
ils se marièrent et eurent beaucoup
d'enfants c'est des conneries tout ça tu
sais très bien
français un truc qui est fait est que
dit rien c'est peut-être qu'il fait
pareil ouais ils se marièrent et eurent
beaucoup d'enfants
avec sur le gaz - ça va
l immortalité manu et voilà ça va sortie
le 25 août et on sent vraiment en voyant
ce film que vous êtes un fou de cinéma
ya bonheur de filmer il ya une
jubilation à filmer il ya des moments où
vous éclater il ya un côté lellouche
dans le plaisir qu'il avait à filmer ya
30 ans quand on sent que ça vous plaît
quoi sa belle cinéma vraiment c'est pour
ça que aussi j'ai eu envie de passer
derrière après 10 ans en devançant parce
que j'aime ça et que si je pouvais même
aller sur un film et faire juste le
casting si je pourrais je sais pas ça se
sent et passionné de cinéma en ce sens
était un fou de cinéma vraiment et une
scène où ils sont avec chabat et alain
cohen tous les trois ou chabab ne pas
remonter chez lui parce qu emmanuelle
seigner lukas vraiment les couilles et
il aimerait que ses copains rester avec
lui et les autres veulent se barrer
parce qu'ils en ont ras le bol et c'est
une magnifique quoi cela n'en finit plus
et dans le hall d'un immeuble un peu un
peu comme ça et trois mecs vendre des
bagnoles enfin c'est pas ils vendent des
bagnoles ils vivent leur vie chacun avec
leur femme leurs enfants et est tout son
nom un peu reculé 2 les deux mariés en
vie la vie du célibataire le célibataire
envie de l'avis des mariés
lui-même se fait un peu chier dans la
ville assure l'étude c'est presque pire
que tout le vch coucher tout seul et on
suit ces trois mecs pendant un long
moment avant de bifurquer au détour
d'une allée chez virgin quand charlotte
ça c'est rien ça c'est terrible c'est
plutôt une belle c'est n'y a aucun mot
qui énerve tout les deux écoutes le même
disque
un rond-point j'imagine comme on peut
écouter de la musique et puis tous les
deux et coutumes et même disque puis il
se passe des choses entre eux sans
qu'ils aient besoin de dire quoi que ce
soit ce qui est très bien aussi dans vos
sims il ya des séquences oniriques comme
ça on sait pas si c'est des des
flashforwards aussi c'est des séquences
imaginaire en pas il ya un peu de tout y
si ça c'est une séquence réel d'ailleurs
elle rentre à la maison elle a acheté le
disque i et puis elle fait la cuisine
les coûts de ce disque on sent bien
qu'ils allaient calais ailleurs il ya
d'autres séquences qui sont imaginaires
et à un moment elle est agent immobilier
charlotte elle fait visiter un
appartement puis tout d'un coup ou deux
comme ça au milieu de la visite
elle se rend compte en faisant visiter
l'appartement de ce que pourrait être la
vie des autres et ce que pourrait être
sa vie et elle s'imagine la vie sans lui
à ce moment là vraiment on part avec
elle dans son imaginaire elle s'imagine
la vie sans son mari se rend compte que
ça va mais moi il vient il lui dit les
enfants c'est toi qui les place et une
scène totalement imaginaire il ya un
mélange de scènes réelles de scène
imaginaire c'est assez c'est assez bien
foutu bon d'être doué ben merci beaucoup
vraiment vous avez une bonne pression là
je pourrais vous les faits un peu dans
votre coin en vous disant bon c'est pas
grave c'est plus difficile de faire un
deuxième film parce que le premier on
n'a absolument rien à perdre
et puis quand le premier à marcher alors
on espère que le deuxième
vous donnera la possibilité de faire le
troisième enfin d'attaqué là le 24 août
vous serez trop de vêtements mais il est
inquiet tout l'été et ceci dit je vais
tourner un film pour mener à bien
marcher le le premier là ma femme est
une actrice bien très bien les mecs qui
étaient faits non est un remake qui a
pas été fait et heureusement parce que
c'est probablement steven spielberg qui
va le faire oh voilà c'est un jeune
metteur en mairie j'ai eu l'occasion de
le rencontrer à paris pour son prochain
film
et puis quand il m'a demandé ce que je
voulais lui montrer pour qu'ils me
voient acteur je lui ai donné un dvd de
mon film et puis
il l'a vu j'étais très étonnée qu'il le
voit le soir même il m'a rappelé le soir
même pour me dire qu'il avait adoré qui
m'a demandé si les droits de remake qui
était pris voilà donc je pense que en
bas on va s'arranger
et c'est bien là dedans alors moi j'ai
retrouvé beaucoup d'interviews
yvan attal vous disiez toujours oui mais
alors vous n'y couperez parfaire le
tableau
oui mais
[Musique]
alors je vous demande simplement de
tenir la phase
j'adore ce film et mais je l'adorent un
point tu peux même pas imaginer
je suis totalement réalisateur du monde
mais mais au moins dans mon film j'ai
les meilleurs acteurs du monde je n'ai
rien contre le mans physique mais mais
d'autres non plus d'ailleurs
vous avez quoi l'oreille là je suis né
comme ça
ah bon je crois que c'était je veux dire
la vérité vous aviez une boucle
d'oreille quelqu'un vous l'avez acheté
je suis très en forme je raconte tout un
baratin comme quoi j'avais une femme et
toi mais là je suis né comme ça ce soir
à dire la vérité pas vous faire chier
jeu plaît beaucoup aux femmes
mais le problème c'est vrai je veux
beaucoup au jeune mais je suis marié je
suis une star chez les gays mais mais
n'y a pas de même mais je n'apprécie pas
spécialement les partouzes mai mais
c'est parce que je suis très jaloux mais
l'un dans l'autre
j'aime pas les sandwichs grecs mais dans
une partouze
je suis pour la paix dans le monde mais
c'est pas gagné
bien à temps
mais 20 heures et j'ai peur des piqûres
vous j'ai peur de mourir mais ça je me
soigne j'ai envie de vous tu as aimé
mais un peu trop de monde y va seul se
marièrent et eurent beaucoup d'enfants
avec alain chabat
votre emmanuelle seigner sortie le 25
août mais la tâche à jouer car bravo
super pays qui va te coucher toi il est
en vie on est trop jeune il est trop
moyen il est tout entre les deux il est
trop mouillé merci sa belle-mère
non
seydou métissé quoi laurent j'ai
retrouvé mon team site de l'époque le
bon client timsit de double jeu le
timsit dardy maths et puis on le voyait
plus trop comme ça et là j'ai retrouvé
ce soir se dit nancy et plein de cartes
suppliant c'est qu'un bon client
[Applaudissements]
mais si ledit de sueur
[Musique]
oui
sur 1 mètre 80 donc je suis obligé une
petite j'ai un petit cube là quand les
filles sont grandement dessous quand tu
étais petit ça peut poser des problèmes
d'être si grande quand même j'étais
grande très vite donc j'étais complexée
à dos les complexés quand il donnait la
main un mec dans la rue on aurait dit
que tu étais sa mère c'était dur les
petits copains à dole et c'est sûr
maintenant ça va mieux
salami copains je connais aussi toujours
le petit peu alors elodie moi j'y
comprends plus rien les derniers jours
dans la ferme il avait que pour vous
tous les résumés quotidiens ne
s'intéresser qu'à vous massimo maxime ya
céline ne tarissait pas d'éloges sur
vous votre sens de l'organisation
le soin vous preniez des animaux massy
moon a dit en parlant de vous elle est
tellement belle
voilà et pourtant vous êtes la troisième
derrière olmeta et eve angeli alors
pourquoi parce que ça s'était bien passé
finalement justement tout c'est
peut-être trop bien passé
1 et la fin de cette troisième et voilà
ce qu'on aime bien je pense que les gens
bien aussi les victimes ou les martyrs
quelque part et depuis le début je suis
entré tels que j'étais gens sortent tant
que tels que je suis je n'ai pas changé
je n'ai le meilleur dès le départ il ya
pas eu d'évolution en fait on y pense
ouais c'est vrai ça tu as suivi un peu
non ouais ouais je la leur gauthier
jacquet la ferme c'était génial non
franchement j'adore 1 a passé des
moments exceptionnels 99
le matin quand il se réveiller il y
avait il à riom un jour il a dit cette
émission ça devrait s'appeler on achève
bien les people
c'est un peu de rêve gros succès alors
non peut-être vous avez été sanctionné
parce que
nous était moins présente au conseil
régional c'est vrai que les français
vous ont sanctionné à cause de ça parce
que la semaine d'avant je suis resté
face à vincent mcdoom donc valence à
cause des déclarations de madame de
fontenay peut-être non non mais je pense
pas les gens ne sont pas idiots et voit
clairement non parce que c'est vrai que
même de faute et cela pas ménagé ali
c'est une ferme d'opérette idiote et
perverse 15000 euros par semaine pour
singer ceux qui travaillent et prennent
jamais de vacances
ce plan politique c'est acceptable la
ferme
moi j'ai regardé qu'une fois parce que
mes enfants regardé et j'ai découvert ce
personnage que j'ai trouvé merveilleux
qui le monsieur dont vous avez parlé que
vincent mcdoom donc essayer des
chaussures il avait chez lui et j'ai
trouvé bon après j'ai pas regardé nous
pas ailleurs on a on a des accointances
puisque vous savez que je suis en
picardie et moi j'ai assisté à
l'installation du conseil régional sur
la ferme j'ai pas regardé au delà j'ai
trouvé se massant mcdoom tout à fait
extraordinaire c'est vrai c'est le
tricoter une écharpe c'est à dire et
vincent c'est assez extraordinaire quand
même c'est que la france se soit
passionné pour les amours de vincent
mcdoom avec olmeta ce qui est d amasser
assez moderne quand même ça madame de
fontenay a eu un argument assez dur elle
dit qu'on ne me parle pas d'association
pourquoi pas un film porno pour la croix
rouge
ah c'est pas con ça c'est pas con dans
des comédies de crime
je vois déjà les moyens ordinaires alors
elle dit que je suis un vrai pour nous
toutes ces questions et à d'autres dans
un livre qui paraît chez michel lafon
qui s'appelle mes rêves mes passions
mais ce soir voilà parler tout parler du
conseil régional de picardie dont vous
accusez la dictature morale vous y êtes
vous à ce conseil régional de picardie
oui alors moi j'étais assez jaloux
puisque elodie est arrivé dans la
campagne avec gilles de robien a été
notre adversaire et je me suis dit ça ça
va être un implacable coire et
finalement je la remercie plutôt vu le
résultat
ce que gilles de robien n'a jamais pris
un revers électoral aussi grand que ça
et puis après pour les éclater en
attendant je la tenais à faire soit vous
pensez que ledit pour quelque chose dans
l'échec de re bien passer de l'un à
l'autre
attendez etienne mougeotte a mis un jet
privé à sa disposition pour qu'elles
puissent assister au concert national de
raison de refuser l'opportunité qui est
l'émission de la pharma en plus en plus
honnêtement tout le monde a un boulot
quand ces régionales de la profession de
tout conseiller régional donc c'est
parce que la mienne et ray et médiatisée
qu'elle ait pas respectable elle a
découvert comme ça que c'est parfois
difficile d'être élu combatif d'autres
plus en fait la réponse est oui
non merci sam affrontement gauche-droite
de première qualité mesdames messieurs
oui je l'aimé bien raffarin vous oui on
est maintenant non j'admire j'admire il
faut qu'elle continue la politique il
faut bien hélas buzz surtout parce
qu'elle a de la fanfare de la mode en
même temps
alors un protêt sans cesse en
plaisantait vous racontez votre désir de
faire de la télé et votre expérience
c'est à dire vous êtes partie à dubaï je
ne savais pas ça vous raconter sans dans
votre bouquin vous partez à dubaï pour
faire une semaine d'animations en
anglais quotidienne le shopping festival
en fait de dubaï c'est bien ça s'est
bien passé très bien une expérience très
enrichissante
il y à un emirati qu'a voulu vous
épousez alors la jeter au départ merci
ça il nous a tout proposé
bien sûr la villa les bijoux qu'est-ce
qu'ils avaient tous tout est en échange
ba je me donnais aller et alors ça vous
a pas un concept à la mode ou du mariage
non c'est pas une question de beauté
c'est que c'est pas mon concept de vente
ont pris surtout vous raconte elodie
gossuin dans ce bouquin ou première
expérience sur les plateaux de télé
quand vous êtes devenu nice france on
vous dit j'étais considéré comme une
demeurée mental qu'il fallait absolument
ménagé par charité chrétienne sur
certaines émissions il ya des préjugés
effectivement et des préjugés pas ici
c'est vrai la première émission que j'ai
fait ici j'étais vraiment à bien traiter
il s'appelle qu'est ce qui veut dire que
ce qu'il a dit je répèterai pas ses
enseignes été mais je me rappelle très
bien
vous avez été moins bien traités
ailleurs ce que vous racontez dans votre
bouquin vous été massacrés dans une
semaine après mon élection et c'était
terrible parce qu'effectivement quoi que
je dise quoi que je fasse ce la réponse
était de été la même sais tu as bien
appris la leçon de la part de madame de
fontenay et je ne pouvais rien dire
j'avais pas la liberté de parole
d'expression je ne pouvais pas donner
mes propres réponses et elle était pour
lui et retrouver son nom qu'un mauvais
souvenir télé un plus mauvais souvenir
télé c'est fogiel
française il choisit les abaisser
il était atterré alors vous raconter nos
histoires d'amour alors mais c'est dans
le bouquin je n'invente rien donc il ya
david première expérience sexuelle jeune
a 16 ans ça s'est passé ou la première
fois à côté de chez moi mais je veux pas
précisé dans un terrain vague
après ya laurent le maître nageur il a
24 ans vous avez 16 en train de couler
et il vous sort c'est l'année où elodie
est élue miss camping est donc
évidemment le mec est maître nageur élue
miss camping comprendre ça crée des
liens
beau comme un dieu
adèle beau comme un dieu un nom il ya eu
un problème avec abdel c'est quand vous
arrivez à paris c'est un peu humain a
marqué l'essai en même temps quand vous
arrivez à paris vous voyez moi quoi et
puis c'est simplement oui là l'évolution
quoi qui est différente
sa rencontre est très jeune et on a
grandi de manière différente
ça arrive voilà et alors adèle vous le
voyez comme le pauvre gars hier à saint
cloud bien sûr quand vous dites on fait
une dînette
c'est une faute de frappe
non seulement on est resté très très
proches mes amis amis ou amis uniquement
à 8 mwh est je suis très fier si un
parent de saint cloud est arrivé
attention bel amour en amitié
ce sont les pires celle là donc on en
arrive à maxime maxime le comique je
précise pour tout le monde
alors là la pression médiatique a eu
raison de votre couple c'est les
paparazzi qu'on oui parce que on nous a
piégés ça fait très peu de temps qu'on
était ensemble donc c'est vrai quand ya
pas encore la confiance et la relation
qui est sincère et staps à détruire quoi
je pense que les médias peuvent détruire
un couple si le cours n'est le couple
n'est pas sûr de lui et enfin de son
amour réciproque
voilà et vous le retrouvez la ferme ce
mec slimer vous saviez qu'il serait là
oui et vous y avez quand même bien sûr
parce qu on était resté en bons termes
entre vous avez draguer à la ferme non
non rien eu
rien du tout le temps avec la famille lu
des trucs avec quelqu'un je ne crois pas
pas ma connaissance des animaux comme
enflé comme moi j'ai vu pour pont boite
et pendant deux semaines
je vais pas balancer moussin mai
bon dans la salle c'est simple on devait
arriver au scoop du bouquin d'elodie
gossuin dire comment il se délecte pas
ce que c'est qu'un parti c'est comme
arditi qui est balancé par ce héros dans
son bouquin mais ce héros dis pas que
c'est arditi là vous dites pas qui c'est
et c'est marrant tout le monde va le
reconnaître comme tout le monde a
reconnu arditi dans le bouquin de ce
héros un journaliste de renom dont je
tairai identité j'ai arrêté dans son
attitude m'a choqué et déçu a également
tenté sa chance
j'avais une certaine admiration pour lui
ne croyez pas ceux qui mettaient en
garde mme assurant que sa moralité était
inversement proportionnelle à sa
suffisance et qu'il ne reculait pas
devant des méthodes journalistiques plus
que douteuse pour se faire mousser
j'y voyais la pure jalousie de la part
de ses détracteurs
jusqu'au j'ai rencontré ferme jusqu'au
jour où j'ai rencontré l'homme en
question dans un studio de télévision
je dois reconnaître qu'il est allé droit
au but sans perdre de temps
côté efficacité rien à dire nous nous
connaissions depuis une heure à peine
qu'il me demandait déjà assis
familièrement tu as quelqu'un en ce
moment comme je suis d'une franchise
indécrottable toujours la ferme
j'ai dit la vérité non je suis seul et
alors là j'ai droit à un numéro
exceptionnel qui me laisse bouche bée
une caricature de drague à l'italienne à
hurler de rire oui tu es seul c'est
normal à tournage il te fous quelqu'un
qui t'apprennent vraiment ce que c'est
l'amour c'est ce que tu attends ce dont
tu as besoin
je vais m'en charger incroyable il ne me
demande même pas mon avis c'est tout
juste il n'ajoute pas et si on
commençait là tout de suite sur la
moquette enlève ta culotte pendant que
je me sers à whisky puis je commence ma
leçon et oubliera pas de dire merci
monsieur tout le monde a compris que
c'était gérard holtz
bien donc si vous savez qui c'est vous
nous répondez vous tapez sur le site
france 2 et le 4 septembre nous vous
donnerons la réponse tout on a compris
dit jusque athlètes non
[Musique]
mais même les patients meilleur
il sait
michel
messieurs
[Musique]
j'accueille maintenant on a bien phare
et c'est cécile cassel
[Musique]
mais bien toutes les deux à la fiche de
pour le plaisir un film de 2 minutes de
rue d'air qui va sortir le 14 juillet
avec samuel le bihan françois berléand
olivier gourmet lorànt deutsch et vous
deux les fastes le pitch
or l'histoire donc dans une petite ville
du nord françois berléand qu'est
garagiste va consulter samuel le bihan
qui est si voilà il dit ma femme c'est
vous sa femme me dit qu'elle ne peut
prendre du plaisir qu'avec des assassins
pas de crime pas d'orgasme
que dois-je faire docteur alors le
docteur lui répond qu' entré dans son
fantasme inventé vous un crime voilà
alors évidemment au moment où le
garagiste s'accuse d'un meurtre auprès
de sa femme un homme est vraiment tué
près de chez lui un mec l'ignoble une
brute épaisse et là vers les andes via
une star c'est ce qui est marrant dans
le film c'est que c'est l'assassin qui
devient une star puisqu'il a tu es un
connard voiture me regardent comme sa
famille du magnifique l'ag d'hier ce
soir c'est vraiment fait un effort
énorme
excuse moi c'est un effort sur le plat
ça se voit tout de suite remarquer
j'ai commencé beaucoup la wii toi aussi
tu es très mignon ça ça te va mieux les
jeux de cette couleur oui pas difficile
mais l'autre fois c'était venu tu étais
un peu ouais un peu que de vaches la
même là c'est joli j'étais j'avais tout
a pas chez moi mais j'aime bien ça
j'aime bien ça bon alors est-ce lui qui
a tué
je parle de berléand le garagiste son
mécano lorànt deutsch ou le psy le bihan
il dit des trucs la vendée le votre fils
oui c'est c'est allé le voir déjà le 14
juin ont fait une énorme fête d'artifice
par la sortie un truc énorme
et puis et puis ben je sais pas il n'y a
pas une bande annonce un truc qui donne
envie pour voir la bande-annonce faut
que tu regardes sa caméra nadia aussi
laquelle c'est le rouge
vous dites magnéto serge attention à
troyes 1 2 3 magnéto non non non je vois
jamais ça il faut le dire encore un deux
trois magnéto serge elle dit que pour
que ça fonctionne mais des fois nature
mais qui a du sang sur les mains
entrez dans son fantasme inventé vous un
tronc
il y avait des ennemis des gens qui lui
en voulaient à l'abri que les zones il
était temps que quelqu'un allait donner
une bonne leçon pour moi c'est quelqu'un
de bien qui fait ça et qui tu ne sais
pas je rêvais s'est tué votre mari ce
soir là
eq l'assurance d'une totale impunité 66%
des personnes interrogées commettre au
moins un an
à combien montrer ce pourcentage si on
leur offrait la gloire ces bons dossiers
c'est votre presse pourquoi
[Musique]
je suis tombée amoureuse de feu
d'après ce que vous dites pour nous mais
que les assassins
[Musique]
elle est au taquet du groupe l'année
vous faites payer cher pour conseiller à
vos clientes comme à 3 heures
la sortie le plat
mais
misano
en 9 h et celle
c'est un film belge un oui avec animaux
humour complètement sujet complètement
insensé comme le décrit le réalisateur
très très drôle et vous c'est si vous
êtes majorettes dans le film vous êtes
obligé de prendre des cours de bâton
exactement
ouais j'ai travaillé en france je suis
bien en belgique merci magnifique suite
les deux langues diraient que j'avais
dans une soirée après ça sent la vie qui
sait ça pétille ça tombe bien c'est
vachement agréable
baloji tu as vu comment il a bronzé
saint saëns et la masia du monsieur
démaquillage
non mais une fois tu es revenu hyper
hyper bronzé et je pensais qu'il était
démis un truc mais très vite je règle
est ma télé comment on les fixe est ce
qu'on va faire mal aux non-musulmans
l'émission là-bas
on va faire une interview déjà dit
[Musique]
est-ce que vous
[ __ ] quel film de merde quand même oui
avec qui je les oublie
j'ai déjà dit les moches mais bon il est
producteur
non moi pas parce qu'à chaque fois je
t'ai non non je suis pas une sainte non
j'ai pas mais j'ai toujours aimé
vraiment quand j'ai été avec un homme
j'ai vraiment aimé je n'ai pas connu de
producteurs non non vous êtes déjà dit
tiens je suis aujourd'hui je joue
vraiment comme une saucisse mois oui
surtout en voyant les films canadiens
non je me suis plutôt dit et j'aurais
aimé être dirigée peut-être d'une autre
façon voilà vous êtes déjà dit
sérieusement avec une fille c'est
peut-être pas mal d'essayer
ben vu comme c'est compliqué avec vous
je tête ni m nadia n'ont jamais essayé
il faut un jour du jeu comme une
saucisse ne peut vous êtes déjà dit non
sans malice et déjà dit allez hop magro
son régime
il ya deux jours j'ai déjà dit en voyant
un mec lui sait où il veut quand il veut
même à damas samedi soit vraiment mon
père regarde et en même temps bah oui
bien sûr un nom mais ce serait de lancer
avoir jamais pensé ça un matin d'hiver
le 16 go boo boo boo boo boc laurent
beauvais
c'est un nouveau truc c'est le bobo tu
brûles quelques alors à quand un antonov
bobos vous êtes déjà dit si si ne fait
pas un carton que j'arrête le cinéma non
arrêté parce que j'ai fait parce que
j'ai pas eu la chance de faire des films
qui ont du succès et celui là mais tout
change les bains
vous êtes déjà les touches les mêmes
finalement non mais t'es que j'ai
rencontré mon mari non à tulle m ce
ch'ti bhl ce qu'ils valent plus que les
autres
non ça m'intéresse qu'est ce qu'il a de
plus que les autres cm je veux quelqu'un
qui est non
c'est l'audi nadia les 22 maxi même fait
c'est non c'est quelqu'un avec qui on
s'entend bien j'irai sur tous les plans
et puis on partage beaucoup de choses
ensemble on se marre ensemble et
voilà et puis c'est quelqu'un qui sait
être doux et qui est profondément bon
mari et voilà c'est ça s'explique pas on
s'est vu la première fois ça a été notre
force est quoi ouais c'était un regard
et ça c'est fait voilà et ça y est ça
continue et oui j'aime ce style ouais
c'était quoi comme genre de regard
c'était un petit regard de cocker
voilà qui met le che matin lorsqu'il a
touché le regard de quelqu'un et je sais
quoi qui touche non mais je sais c'est
un ensemble
je suis vieux
non pour le plaisir très belle mére
surréaliste visage face à son destin
tu vas meoli toi magie va travailler ma
folie avec lui j'en sais rien moi tu vas
le film est gentil s'imposer voilà voilà
en tous les cas c'est demain 15h30 sur
france 5 pour les falbalas de jean paul
gaultier documentaire de tonie marshall
merci à tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'y vais et maintenant ça
bah
g
m
tha
chez moi
ouais si lula
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
booba mon soir tiens les cheveux
extrêmement bien coupé non mais vraiment
un jeu trop non avec bada je suis
fascinée là vraiment ça va très très
bien dire fou ce lien vous bien alors
booba il rigole plus
tu rigoles pas attention je suis ça va
mal 27 ans 2 album certifié disque d'or
deux passages en prison
on commence par la prison comme ça ça
sera fait donc d'abord quatre ans pour
avoir agressé deux chauffeurs de taxi et
qu'une arme à feu je suis liberté
conditionnelle au bout de 18 mois
pourquoi parce que j'étais ça marche
alors c'était pas méchant ils ont été un
peu dur avec moi ensuite quatre mois de
préventive pour tentative d'homicide
volontaire l'ats le procureur a réclamé
trois ans mais vous avez été relaxé
parce que j'étais innocent ouais tu
regrettes je regrette de m'être fait
rattraper surtout me
tu dis que les gens qui sont en prison
en fait y en a très peu qui elle va tu
attends qu on sait pas faire attraper
je me connais peu qu'ils vont se rendre
de leur plein gré pour moi aussi je
regrette ce que j'ai fait ou alors vous
êtes booba métisse franco sénégalais
mais dans les hauts-de-seine vers 10-11
ans quand vos parents divorcent vous
partez avec votre mère à cagnes-sur-mer
et bt de vos quinze ans vous avez aux
usa et vous dites est là c'est
intéressant par rapport à ce que dit
payant non je ne crois pas du tout à
l'intégration
je préfère le système des communautés à
l'américaine donc vous pensez que
l'intégration républicaine à la
française c'est un modèle obsolète
ouais je pense que c'est hypocrite ouais
on aimait chez soi avec les gens qui
nous ressemblent c'est pas sans être
sectaire mais ouais aux états unis voilà
quoi côté américain on se retrouve
ensemble ils font ensemble à manhattan
par exemple n'y a pas de problème les
soirées se retrouve chez eux ils n'ont
pas de tensions ils sont d'ordre 1 à
noter avec les gens qui on ne regarde
pas de doute en bas chacun chez soi
moi je préfère en tout cas un modèle où
on peut avoir des gens qui sont divers
et qui vivent ensemble plutôt que d'être
chacun dans son coin et je pense quand
même que ce modèle est un modèle qui
amène entre ces communautés à des
violences qui sont extrêmement profonde
et avec des communautés qui sont quand
même beaucoup plus en difficulté que
l'autre ça me semble pas un modèle très
souhaitable je pense qu'on avait réussi
à faire ensemble c'est difficile à faire
alors qu'on dit je moi je préfère l
autre avec ceux qui sont comme moi etc
on le comprend tous parce qu'on a tous
un peu ça mais de là à dire sans les
autres c'est difficile mais j'ai fait
une interview l'année dernière à la
prison fleury mérogis et je leur
expliquais que éventuel 20 je leur
posais la question à savoir la d'être en
prison maintenant ici est ce que ça leur
permettait à eux d'avoir une remise en
question sur eux-mêmes et éventuellement
d'évoluer devoirs et les gammes disait
non parce qu'en fait on nous replonge
comme il veut mettre par secte par
secteur c'est ça maintenant
communautaire présence illégale et on
nous replonge dedans sion si
effectivement nous mettez un petit peu
là là là là là on serait en fait on se
retrouve tous les mêmes qui étaient dans
les cités à faire des conneries se
retrouvent par elles sont donc ils
peuvent pas évoluer il n'y a pas deux il
n'y a pas un vrai travail et un suivi
pour essayer justement de le leur ouvrir
d'autres horizons pas pour portes pour
vous l'avenir et tout communautarisme en
fait vous pensez que l'intégration
républicaine c'est un modèle dépassé
je pense en tout cas ici ça pense pas à
prendre ouais ça marche pas parce que
vous dites vous par exemple quand il
fallait me réinscrire au collège
ma mère me disait te montre pas comme sa
mère elle est blanche s'en passe mieux
ouais
par exemple vous dites en france même
avec une belle voiture tu te fais
contrôler deux fois par jour il ya
toujours vous dites ce plafond qu'on
n'arrive pas à percer khwaja quelles que
soient les moyens dont on dispose
quand on est noir on sera toujours un
sous citoyen c'est ce que vous dites en
fait moi je pense avoir pensé que c'est
sans espoir
je sais pas trop d'espoir à ce niveau là
c'est quand même
mais s'ils disent ah enfin moi ce que
j'entends c'est qu'en même temps il ya
une forme de regret parce que je vois
pas pourquoi il serait pas un citoyen
comme les autres donc ça condamne pas le
modèle républicain ça dit il
ils marchent mal classés c'est 800 qui
marche mal mais où qu'ils marchent pas à
mon avis ça marche mieux quand même que
là où il n'ya pas mais et il a des ratés
terrible il a des ratés depuis 20 ans
considérable et d'ailleurs on voit les
brisures moi ça me donne plutôt le
sentiment qu'il faudrait que ça marche
mieux grandir ce modèle la seule réponse
tous savent laborieux il ya des gens qui
croient plus du tout âge et bien c'est
inquiétant vous dites je raconte la dure
réalité le mal de vivre
si on mettait mes textes en images ce
serait sûrement interdit aux moins de 16
ans
peu des textes extrêmement violent il ya
même dans votre cd rom en violant ex
dans votre cd qui bâtiment c'est quand
même pas reproduit sur le livre est
tellement il est violent c'est pour
éviter les ennuis avec la justice traîne
d'orange pour ce texte
1 mais violent mais bon pour moi c'est
énorme alors votre nouvel album qui est
le deuxième album solo vous faites booba
s'appelle panthéon c'est chez barclays
vous pensez que cette musique ce genre
de texte devrait avoir sa place au
panthéon
forcément c'est plus un symbole
l'histoire dira qu'on essaye de faire de
grandes choses quoi ouais vos chansons
racontent les gonzesses les flingues les
flics il est bon de les citer la cam est
la plus sympa tout c'est numéro 10 c'est
la plus optimiste des trois numéros 10
heures par un grand palace du siècle l'a
offert
numérotée en maths et vents forts
hertz mme parisot
au plus on serre la main
verbe haut
numérotée saint martin orlando exige le
clip officiel n'est pas numérotées
s'empara drap alain du siècle là où son
père en brossant les victimes de les
numéroter en maths et brossard ce que
l'on perd ce monsieur rizzoli serbe
imprime nom rime sur leur règne au
bulldozer la aux ovaires on peut
les victimes
numéro des hommes à pied dans le rap qui
créé produit et je suis chauffeur
livreur beaucoup de larmes mon
enterrement entouré chip frères negro on
plaisante pas avec le pipeau qu 0-0
contre on n'attend pas tomber malade
évitez chez barclays
ah oui ça c'est le plus sympa de 6
numéros 10 plus en positif
alors on vous compare à jeûner on vous
compare à céline et c'est vrai que
finalement on pourrait dire que je n'ai
céline c'était des rappeurs sans musique
personnellement moi je n'ai pas lu je
connais pas dit ce qu'ils font c'est que
c'est des grands écrivains m j'en sais
pas plus connais pas ces lignes rouges
il pas belles chansons alors vous êtes
le 25 août à bercy avec fives 600 voix
en première partie c'est bien vous
sourirez jamais qu'est ce qui pourrait
vous faire plaisir car deux membres
entre de tes questions à la con
nous sommes
[Musique]
vincent je vais t'envoyer de coucher
avec merci la barre et qui a vécu
les
et maintenant hélas
j'aime
[Musique]
voici nicolas rey et nous y sommes
ça va très bien la très bien la nana
fois que tu es venu on avait eu louis
l'anr par raccroc aujourd'hui il vient
vraiment pour la sortie de son livre qui
s'appelle un pur roman c'est publié
évidemment au diable vauvert comme tout
ce que vous faites tous les deux vous
êtes au diable vauvert
voilà le pitch louis basset histoire de
virgile qui à 26 ans qui comme beaucoup
de gens rêvent de faire de la télé et
donc il s'imagine pas que le dernière
univers rock n roll dans lequel il va
pouvoir s'amuser c'est justement la télé
il pense qu'il va pouvoir sortir avec
des filles plus belle que qu'ailleurs
qui va pouvoir faire des choses
extraordinaires comme peut-être partir
en week-end avec avec séverine ferrer
faveur des choses comme ça c'est magique
dans ce livre il est là il veut devenir
une star il n'est pas le seul on veut
tous devenir des stars maintenant c'est
pour ça qu'aujourd'hui suis très content
d'être enfin invite officiellement j'ai
vu venir sans sens on s'en tape et le
vigile à l'entrée
il y avait même une demie loges pour moi
voilà un verre de champagne donc c'est
magique savalou j'ai dit à un extrait
d'un pur roman ça bien énervé booba ma
vie comme tous les enfants riches
je suis beau les papas riche épouse de
belle maman je suis l'ultime
aboutissement de cette sélection par
l'argent comme tous les beaux enfants je
serai bientôt une star j'ai du temps
pour ça je n'ai pas besoin de dépenser
mon énergie à gagner ma vie ma vie est
déjà gagné
j'ai une [ __ ] de longueur d'avancé sur
vous pendant que vous serez bloqué dans
la queue du casting de la star academy 6
j'aurais déjà écrit le scénario de la
star ac 7
la vie est injuste je suis la preuve
vivante que notre pays n'est pas une
république que les hommes ne naissent
pas égaux en droits et le demeure encore
moins je ne suis pas votre égal mais si
vous pouviez croire en cette égalité
révolutionnaire ça m'arrangerait bien
pensé que tout le monde peut être star
sur les conseils démocratiques des profs
qui vous demande de rester vous-même
surtout restez vous mêmes ne changez
rien vous êtes parfait
c'est ce qu'on appelle les pirates
eurent tête à claques fessées mais c'est
pas mal
là tu te démerdes oui en même temps
c'est toi qui l'a écrit c'est vrai
provoquant louis en fait moi je n'ai
rien à voir avec ce héros en fait moi
j'ai je suis à garçon très tendres j'ai
eu une histoire d'amour un petit peu
compliqué avec une fille qui s'appelle
céline et qui me regardera pas ce soir
et c'est une fille pas mal si je peux
faire rêver un petit peu les gens qu'est
ce que je peux dire elle a 25 ans bon ça
déjà ça fait rêver je pense ensuite elle
a un tatouage de salamandre sur la
hanche droite
elle a une peau couleurs sucrées mais
vraiment sucre de canne
un petit peu un petit peu comme toi
elodie et mais c'est vrai que c'est vrai
que pour moi c'est difficile et pas de
carte de fermer ta gueule c'est pas mal
écrit c'est très très bien c'est bien
écrit c'est bien écrit mais c'est
énervant
oui mais comme toutes les choses un peu
comme ça qu'ils sont comme ça à ce point
réussie si les monty python avaient fait
l'amour avec des proches se redonner
louis lannes hervé mons a pas été le cas
et en plus il ya un plaisir de lecture
immédiat évident la phrase de tolstoï on
oublie qu'on lit vraiment et moi j'ai eu
les mêmes fini alors ton premier j'avais
pas son premier livre j'avais moins
finie est ce que je suis les non gelée
fini je les trouvais formidable c'est
pas le voyage au bout de la nuit non
plus aimé pour l'été c'est excellent
comme on arrive quasiment en serrant
thibout pas d'une certaine façon je suis
pas le bad boy de la littérature on peut
pas dire ça marrant c'est en même temps
il est très sauvages parfois
je m'en suis rendu compte lors de votre
prochain livre vous dites vous avez
changé complètement de style vous allez
décrire une enfance asthmatiques j'avais
pas de papa et où vous allez faire
pleurer un peu que finalement peut-être
que ça pourrait mieux fonctionner dans
notre prochain livre ce qu'on va
peut-être écrire à nicolas que cet
enfant je t'en parle maintenant là parce
qu'on a envie on aurait le dit mais je
pense aussi à livrer quatre ont regardé
la ferme tous les soirs avec louis à lui
s'y connaît et nous on avait une c'est
vrai une vision des miss france
un peu comme ça impeccable au ph neutre
et tout et vous il y avait quelque chose
d'un peu d'un peu salée joli à regarder
comme si vous sentiez la sueur et ça
c'était boire mais n'ont pas créé en
non c'est vrai c'est vrai louis
l'honneur c'est un petit peu sur les
traces de frédéric beigbeder de nicholas
ray enfin cette cette nouvelle
littérature qu'on peut appeler un peu la
littérature tête à claques donc un taux
des jeunes gens riches et beaux qu ils
le proclament et ça énerve les autres
ouais mais c'est parce que moi j'avais
une mère prof de français après fo prof
de philo un grand père prof de patois
lorrain donc j'essaie de me projeter la
demande sur sa vente en sortir c'est
entre beigbeder nicholas ray vous
préférez qui a souvent on associe
nicolas rey et beigbeder et je suis
c'est étrange parce que je trouve que
c'est pas du tout la même littérature en
valoir on va faire une interview nicolas
rey contre beigbeder et c'est vous qui
répondait
louis celui qui couche avec les plus
jolies filles c'est nicholas ray ou
frédéric beigbeder
je connais moi je connais moi celle
celle de frédéric beigbeder toi c'est
que tu es assez sage ces derniers temps
on peut un peu lire celui qui écrit les
meilleurs livres cd dvd ou nicolas rey
fait gaffe luis et acariâtre qui sont
ces gens là quel est le plus important
est ce que c'est mieux de se fâcher que
nicholas ray avec des déchets pas trop
ce qu'est ce que tu veux je crois que
nicolas est en train de monter en
puissance et pas pareil peut-être que
nicolas plus de facilité et du mal et
plus plus la série polluer c'est celui
qui tient le mieux l'alcool dans les
soirées c'est nicolas et vous faites
avec beigbeder
il ya eu quelques soirées qu'est ce
qu'on fait ce concept effet comme sera
le colisée il y avait la soirée champomy
c'était très bien mais ça c'était bien
on a fait une soirée qui viennent
également frédéric et est torché en fait
on l'avait vu en attirant si c'est pas
du tout celui qui est le plus à l'aise
devant une caméra c'est nicolas rey o
frédéric beigbeder c'est certainement
pas moi je crois qu'on l'aura compris je
suis si tu vois celui-ci toi t'as pas
besoin de choix suicide toi c'est ce
soir c'est ce soir est ce que est ce que
je peux peut-être vous rappelez faire un
vote par par sms jeune amar si votre
frédéric deux silhouettes nicolas le
plus à l'aise plus à l'aise dans les
personnages et frédéric celui qui finira
grand écrivain c'est beigbeder ou
nicolas et ses soeurs et blanc ça je
reconnais mais y accueillait toujours
tout public est sous tension
l'udc s'est dit c'est horrible de voir
un jeune écrivain ces talentueux se
chier dessus en direct
celui qui finira par une overdose dans
les toilettes du vip ses fruits avec
bill gray lucio nicolas des points une
overdose de quoi on avait parlé tout à
l'heure de la tisane qu'est ce qu'il ya
comme il ya vu des overdoses frédéric
aime bien les bonbons c'est vrai faut
qu'il fasse attention ils peuvent
grossir et un peu pour celui qui est
moins insupportable qu'il en a l'air
c'est beigbeder ou nicolas rey nicolas
rey est encore plus gentil qu'il en a
l'air il a jamais là t'as jamais les
rats supportable c'est vrai gros melon
bon melon c'est terrible mais je sais ce
que je te fais là s'est tarie moi quand
j'étais petit j'ai arraché des ailes des
mouches ouais tu me compare à une mouche
c'est ça j'ai l'impression de faire
évacuer les bas non dommage celui qui
vous énerve le plus si vous ne
connaissiez pas assez nicolas avec des
délais mais je ne les connais tous les
deux qu'après 22h je pense que je les
connais pas vraiment en fait je pense
que beigbeder une bonne faculté être
énervant alors le plus superficiel des
deux c'est lequel j'avais mon j'emploie
très peu de motifs de s'ouvrir les
veines tout près et puis il ya du matos
on peut s'arranger mais on peut avoir
une lame de rasoir est celui qui est le
plus opportuniste et de ses nicolas et
frédéric beigbeder barralon beigbeder on
l'a vu dès qu'il est l'occasion de faire
une grande émission de télé la fête lier
j'y avais participé et ça a très bien
marché donc je pense que les deux sont
des grand routes on m'a donné l'occasion
de répondre à celui qui a la plus grosse
[ __ ] ses frais
nicolas rêve d'ailleurs pas s'invite sur
la quatrième de goom
s'il ya une [ __ ] de diable par contre
une grosse [ __ ] de dire si c'est des
formes différentes y en a c'est plus une
berline et l'autre il pousse un coupé
sport maintenant ce qu'il faut que je
rentre dans les détails
ces dernières invité de la saison en
même temps tu payes pour les autres
[Musique]
là
le froid
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pour ce dernier blind test nous
allons tester une nouvelle formule la
battle
donc il faut deux dj et j'accueille
accès le dauphin et chris de
multifunkshun
là
aldi et serait pas là
bonsoir bonsoir crise bonsoir excellent
donc pendant la première partie c'est à
dire le par équipes
vous enverrez un titre chacun et au
moment des banques aux vous enverrez
chacun vos titres en même temps ce qui
sera encore plus difficile évidemment
voilà quatre titres très très très
difficile alors il ya deux guest star ce
soir avec nous il ya jean edouard lipa
et pascal sellem
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
jean edouard là on vient de commencer
une nouvelle pièce à la comédie de paris
qui s'appelle le talon d'achille way qui
se joue tous les soirs à 21h30 avec
daniel jean colloredo frédéric ses nerfs
marion dumas et douce l'idée real vient
la commune de paris le talon d'achille à
la comédie de paris at war et
l'instruction en ce moment je prépare un
deuxième dvd
ah ouais je vais premier que des inédits
que jésus mais ouais 100% bien bien tu
es prêt à les aider
bah oui axel vas-y tu interprètes
[Musique]
allison ac dc
et pourtant
dida
bolden
m
non
mais qu'est ce que c'est alors est aussi
connue plaide en sa ouais mais c'est qui
remet dans un petit box
m
oh
personne ces eaux là attention
easy rider non bon donc c'est zéro
partout ccp nouvelles révélations
[Musique]
zéro partout match nul pour le moment à
tout actrice
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais bougez pas beau
un point pour l'équipe de pascal sellem
1 1 et 0 pour soi laurent parce que la
vie est injuste
non c'est pas encore là c'est sa
maintenance et après pour y penser
attention axel jagger
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
bien donc là on est à 2 pour l'équipe de
pascal sellem est assez on y rit parce
que la vie est un grand spa maintenant
attention non échange
oui
[Applaudissements]
ses caprices
oh
m
et les faits
la bourre à toi seul
m
non non et non
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
hier
suivant
[Musique]
oui
c'est une chanson reprise par shell a
bien entendu reprise batsheva et sur la
demande
la bande du dernier tarantino mais lassé
par stevie wonder
bravo on en est où ma ligne ça fait deux
points vrai pour l'équipe de laurent
baffie trois points pour l'équipe de
pascal sellem on continue à toi
il
2 4 attention à toi ni le sien
oh
[Musique]
c'est bien pour une fille de l'ump je
m'inscris non inscrits ouais t'as pas
osé bien axel du nord ouais bravo et bon
on comprend pourquoi l'illustration
musicale de ton film est tellement bonne
tu t'y connais à toi
[Musique]
dina bell howell
[Applaudissements]
pas
d
six races locales c'est un petit peu au
taquet à côté leur monte en puissance et
monte en puissance et d'une terreur en
même temps doit tout leur bonheur des
nombreux attention victor c'est à toi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
5-5 forme ovale 5,5
ouais attention
maintenant c'est tout bah ouais mais bon
[Musique]
parce que l'état
attention axel et beatles non on nous
oublie
non on ne peut pas baser dépassement
on ne souffle pas
mais non
[Musique]
michy donovan
de 9 ans
bon
[Applaudissements]
m
donc c'est vous qui marquait le point
jusqu'à la personne qui a trouvé deux
secrétaires bravo merci madame manage
avoir écouté l'original quand c'est
sorti comme moi voilà très bien on
continue c'est très très dur maintenant
c'est à toi qui
[Musique]
ouais
oui
comment il a affrimé ce soir la maison
on continue axel
mais nancy
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
alors à l'issue du père équipe on est à
7 7
voilà alors là je vais être obligé
d'envoyer un morceau et puis pour faire
choisir les gens voient là parce qu'il
faut agca attention dites moi qui sait
c'est donc l'équipe de basket c'est là
qu'il enclenche alors voila tu cet
ancien navire est un droit qui la donne
est débout bas mais bon beaucoup de
figuration je dois dire maintenant c'est
très compliqué parce qu'on arrive donc
au chacun pour sa gueule
chacun pour sa gueule je sais pas mais
on n'a jamais répéter ça voilà pourquoi
pourquoi barreau parce que la vie est
injuste et voilà et vous le savez
maintenant
alors donc là vous avez joué chacun les
morceaux en même temps évidemment ça va
être extrêmement compliqué c'est la
battle c'est le bastard mix attention à
vous
[Musique]
la maman
non le bon
en vo
m
non
[Musique]
c'est unique
h et non écoutés
[Musique]
on passe au suivant on passe au suivant
attention à vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
du groupe
[Musique]
ça
ok
la vitre au pôle nord m
dans le fixe
[Applaudissements]
y aller
kelly corre
[Musique]
c'est un chanteur
le candidat walo quoi
je mendie
dumas
[Musique]
d'accord
négatif
un ça va
[Musique]
et
pascal voilà évidemment pascal et
laurent toujours les mêmes voilà
intentions l'ultra banco c'est
extrêmement compliqué ce sont deux
chanteuses et voulait jouer en même
temps
[Musique]
non
m
[Musique]
on n'est pas
oh
ouais
non
comment t'as fait effectivement c'est
jay-z
il a trouvé les deux mairies tu as
trouvé thierry chaplin et paula abdul et
je dois gagner le blind test c'était une
trabant qu est le dernier des sept
deniers
c'est quand même
non non c'est sûr que cécile cassel
tu as trouvé les 200 plus c'est bien sûr
une folle à 12 par midam la raie manta
fait janis joplin c'est une bonne
chanteuse préférée et paula abdul moment
voilà vous personne n'a trouvé je sais
pas prévoir de long a dit plein de trucs
et puis ça ce n'est un peu 90 81 pour la
boule progresser bien respect un
vraiment un merci à tous merci à laurent
baffie
kg ha
chez oh éditions monsieur paradis 1
jean pierre marielle ça sort le 21
juillet et puis à hocine album de
vanessa paradis
avec les vis ta vie tu sois là patrick
timsit en deutsch l'américain veut
battre les crimes site avec lorànt
deutsch thierry lhermitte et me
sortie le 7 juillet et la bande
originale de l'america le 6 juillet avec
akhenaton et faf larage voilà vincent
peillon les milliards noir du
blanchiment chez hachette littératures
jean paul gaultier
et tonie marshall les fans veulent
jean paul gaultier le tonie marshall
dimanche deux mains sur tes voilà jean
paul gaultier l'exposition 20 couture
par jean paul gaultier jusqu'au 10
octobre à la fondation cartier pour
l'art contemporain il aura table
se marièrent et eurent beaucoup
d'enfants de yvan attal a
et qui va à tahar
charles bien pour aly kébé alain chabat
c'est nier et johnny depp ça sort le 25
août madame elodie gossuin mes rêves mes
patients médias
c'est chez michel lafon nadia paraît
cécile cassel pour le plaisir
r avec nadia kaci lequel samuel
landes gentil le guen s'en suit
booba l'album s'appelle panthéon et il
sera le 25 août à bercy avec pipe
systems sur première partie et le 25
septembre à bercy
voilà booba louis lemay
un pur roman c'est publié au diable
vauvert
nicolas rey pour ya 30 ans publiée
également au diable vauvert
voilà
c'était tu mens pas au rendez-vous à
rentrer
et d'ici là
l'opinion publique lundi
150 c'est sur france 2 merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
2 300 films et babouche cheval doit se
passer pour lui c'est sûr le pays dans
cette super tafia trop plein j'ai beau
chercher je trouve pas dream en
poussette de basket dans l'air les
troubles mettaient nous sommes en rien à
faire baba bâ mamadou c'est l'heure de
mettre une petite touche 2 est deuxième
mais dis donc
[Musique]
madoff
c'est
la vision rouge faute du gauche 2
garçons temple c'est ce que tu
[Musique]